so
all right welcome everybody we are
standing by for
night two of the republican national
convention we're here again for the
craziness we're here for it together and
we're gonna do
uh the best we can to sort of uh survive
it i guess
for lack of a better term um
many of you were here yesterday and were
very disturbed
by what we saw um
let's give it another shot we are uh i
set today's member target to yesterday's
actual number which was 56
why not you know something to entertain
ourselves uh we've also by popular
demand have twitch
subscribers on screen which any number
of people asked for
let's take a look at what's scheduled
for today um
let's see what we've got here uh
tuesday schedule
let's take a look i know melania will be
speaking today okay
tuesday let's go to tuesday uh
first lady melania trump is slated to
speak also we will hear from secretary
of state mike pompeo
can kentucky senator rand powell iowa
governor kim reynolds
eric and tiffany trump we're also going
to hear from one of the covington kids
nick sandman
if you can imagine something crazier um
and who knows who else that's today
there
is a bingo card that shion created
it's pretty damn funny i i'm not gonna
play along today
but i am going to uh oh that's weird
where did the twitch subscribers go hold
on a second
oh oh oh okay they'll be back they'll be
back don't worry about that um
i'm gonna put this i'm gonna put the
link to this in the twitch chat a few
times
and then also now in the youtube chat a
few times
i may play along i may not but i wanted
to at least get this to you guys there's
some good squares joe biden in a
basement references
reference to communism fascism or
marxism not everything is spelled
correctly this is not mine
but but i wanted to present it to you in
case you'd like it
references to law and order male in
ballot fraud convalescent plasma
the 1917 spanish flu of the failing new
york times washington post references to
israel crazy bernie
nasdaq now this more applies to trump on
thursday i don't know that this applies
today
um border wall i've done more for the
black community than anybody except
maybe lincoln
lying is a free space slurred speech
we'll be watching for
fake protesters or anarchists the china
virus or kung
flu nobody was or is better at x than i
am
second amendment god tax cuts obamacare
make america great again sniffing
the democrats are going to take away x
like the suburbs for example
and a reference to the witch hunt hoax
so i i love that shion
sent that to me i don't it's not perfect
but
it's a work in progress and um
i think it's uh it's a beautiful
beautiful thing to have
okay so our twitch sub counter is
working be gray
rippo's belltown and yeetgree subscribed
and there we go we went from 1301 to
1304
beautiful a few key moments from oh
by the way much like yesterday i will
be live tweeting if the mood should
strike and you can follow my tweets at d
pacman we'll also be very closely
monitoring donald trump's tweets
for example 47 minutes ago he tweeted
again about ballots
and i responded merely panic so we'll be
monitoring donald trump's tweets as well
um some interesting moments from
yesterday let me see which ones i had
here
oh speaking of abolishing things here's
the gun-toting couple the mcclockskies
that's what i call them saying tr a
biden will get rid of the suburbs
to abolish the suburbs all together by
ending
single-family home zoning yep so that
was crazy
um then we had oh these are these are
like mislinked i see
um this was maybe one of the craziest
moments of the entire thing i don't know
if you guys
remember this destroy this country
and everything that we have fought for
and hold dear
they want to steal your liberty your
freedom
they want to control what you see and
think and believe so that they can
control
how you live
they want to enslave you to the weak
dependent
liberal victim ideology to the point
that you will not
recognize this country or yourself so
that was really crazy and then this is
maybe the craziest moment
ladies and gentlemen leaders and
fighters for
freedom and liberty and the american
dream
the best is yet to come
right so that was the um that was the
crescendo of the entire thing
uh let me see what else i've got i guess
that's mostly it
um this was a moment that didn't get the
attention it deserved this was brilliant
donald trump brought workers to talk to
him
and i believe these were workers who had
gotten coronavirus and recovered
and this worker on the end here mentions
that they're a custodian
in a school and you can tell trump
doesn't know what that means
trump doesn't know what a custodian does
it's an unbelievable moment this didn't
get nearly the attention that it
deserved
how about you i'm a custodian at the
post office as well
what do you do exactly clean up
everybody's mess and everybody's germs
and
all that that that world that profession
will never be out of business so uh okay
so it's a custodian at a post office i
guess i misstated that but trump
anybody who like went to school and
related normally to the school you know
the custodian you know all about the
custodian and and how that's
that's the thing trump just has no idea
what that is which was a really really
strange moment
um okay um
what else do i have here
uh
i guess we're in pretty good shape oh i
have a bunch of stories from tomorrow
about how um
100 people are already infected at
purdue university i guess
the entire school starting thing i'm
going to deal with that tomorrow
i also think i'm going to pull up a
secondary stream of the rnc
in case they don't immediately go live
here on people
i like the smoothness of the pbs stream
yesterday
but i'm worried they may not be going
live
exactly when we want to go live so i'm
just gonna grab
one other stream i like to have backup
streams
if really really important there we go
um
okay so we're going to have that and i
know i had other things to talk to you
guys about oh yeah people are noticing
my hair is very controlled today i did
control it
i did control i just thought it would be
appropriate to control it today because
of what what we're dealing with
um okay so we're standing by for the
start of the of the second night
oh um do i want to do this now or do i
want to wait a little bit maybe i'll
actually i'll wait a little bit on this
let me review some of the super chats
that are coming in because there's so
many
um chakuseki says sorry i'm late ghastly
and ghoulish guilfoyle beguiles all with
a garish speak and gargoyle-esque gays
gruesome beautiful alliteration i like
that
seems like some something strange is
going on upstairs cameron titus says
kimberly took the crazy crown last night
over gates and jim jordan in my opinion
who do you think will be the craziest
speaker of day two
um maybe pompeo i mean it's really hard
to say i'm not sure we're gonna watch it
c says did you hear the leaked audio of
reagan saying racist things with richard
nixon what do you think of it i didn't
but
it's not surprising sabrina watts asks
if i've ever owned an
animal yes when i lived in argentina as
a young boy
i owned a turtle and the turtle
died it got into bleach and
i remember being very very upset when my
turtle died
unknown prodigy says cat or dog what's
your first choice dog
dog absolutely um patrick asher says
david
do you love black people of course
of course thanks to oliver wilde for the
subscription colin underwood says ready
to start crying already the
disconnection from reality yesterday was
depressing
yeah you know one bit of sort of good
news is that even though there was more
interest on my stream in yesterday's
um first day compared to the dnc
the ratings were actually down trump's
obsessed with ratings but three million
fewer people watched yesterday uh
relative to i don't know if it was the
first day or the average of the dnc
um so that that's interesting certainly
uh thanks to km as well as perturbo
ruckabow and extra high for the support
over
on twitch we do have uh twitch
subscribers on screen now and i
apologize i've got to turn my phone down
because
it people are just so wound up
everybody's
texting me about uh some of these uh
crazy events that are going on let me
say thank you to
amkar ramachandran who is kicking us off
today as new member number one at
jointpakman.com and
seamus o'dwyen who is new member number
two today
at joinedpakman.com i very much
appreciate that
um what else we are
scheduled to start very very soon i mean
really now they're starting with the
conspiratorial videos already pbs
newshour seems to be running a little
late so we'll stick over here
by the way there's something very ugly
that happened
uh with regard to the fight for one
million subscribers as many of you
may know we are dangerously close to a
million subscribers on youtube we're at
966
966 000 um
we were just in a race against ourselves
where we wanted to get to a million
before election day
um but enlightened centrist tim poole
hit a million subscribers and a lot of
people in the audience wrote to me
despondent i mean just
break broken down emotionally
um and he has beaten us there
so this definitely amps up the urgency
for us to get to
one million um and you know i have my
thoughts on the entire thing
but it is uh it is imperative at this
point
uh that we that we do what we can to get
ourselves to a million and by the way
things going beautifully on twitch as
well we're close to 47
000 and powering towards uh 50
000 over 1300 subscribers as you can see
far above my head
so a lot of really really exciting
things the requisite does david read
twitch chat
has been asked this is every stream
there's a question does david read
twitch chat yes let's get that
out of the way now so we don't have to
continue dealing with it
over and over and over and over again
uh the second night of the republican
national convention
is getting underway we will be hearing
from melania who
we just learned i have a clip about this
actually up on
on my youtube channel she has been
caught on tape
saying disparaging things about both
donald trump and his children that are
not
her children including in particular i
guess she unloads on
ivanka so that is going to be
particularly interesting
we always skip the prayers we skipped it
with the dnc we'll skip it with the rnc
uh super chats continue to send them in
they will pop up on the screen james
buccino says i'd rather fight king kong
and gaku i'm kidding i'm kidding i know
that it's
goku at once uh then have another four
more years of the mango menace
brendan sayer has grabbed the sub diane
marzini
hey that diane says hello from scorching
hot tucson arizona love the show keep
doing what you're doing
you have my support thank you diane i
appreciate that
emmanuel kant says david it's 2 25 in
the morning for me i hope the waiting
will be worth it from the standpoint
of cringe oh there is going to be cringe
to go around german media is having lots
of fun with guilfoyle's manic episode
yeah it was an
episode i don't that's actually a pretty
good way to describe it
it really was an episode aaron dada says
rnc speaker just got pulled
because of anti-semitic post and not
surprising by the way
but five minutes before i came on air
i saw people on twitch already got ban
hammered people were
ranting in uh with racist uh
uh it was like a racist episode i guess
we would call it on twitch
people already banned on twitch before
today's stream even started which is not
good i mean it doesn't bode well for
night two
does not bode well other super chats
coming in
uh stacy weisse says david remember say
i'm hispanic periodically throughout the
night yes one of my big takeaways from
yesterday is i need to announce my
hispanic heritage
randomly and out of context so
i do want to say thanks to a few new
members and remember that i'm hispanic
uh helen march is new member number
three on my website
and griffin boyd is new member number
four
uh they claim to be against identity
politics
and yet and yet everybody yesterday
every speaker who
[Music]
wasn't white i guess making sure that we
knew that
um
zest the african asks from the
standpoint of trump having a wife that
refuses to show public affection towards
him does the cult-like following for the
rnc viewers bother you
everything about this bothers me jeffrey
geltman says
would you go to a seder with sam cedar
or would he cheat to find the offi komen
i would anticipate that
sam would on principle refuse to even
acknowledge the relevance of the offi
coman that would be my expectation
um oliver wilde says did anyone send you
an enhanced buff guy pacman jiff
or gif we will need it tonight
unfortunately no
yesterday i did put up on screen
um buff deep fake pacman and i said i
would only do it if people send me
custom memes using it and nobody did
so it was a huge waste of my time and
everybody's time
unfortunately um
thomas neil says one hit from the bong
every time a republican breathes okay
that's weird
uh at some point we're going to get to
something relevant guys
and i will i will go to uh to this
um but again the priority is to cover
the top
you know the main speakers i don't
understand why pbs is not
covering it live yesterday they did let
me maybe i need oh i see
here it is this is a different stream i
prefer this stream so we're going to
stick with this stream for the time
being
uh dnc had higher first night numbers
says joey two times yes i went over that
already
donna williams says what do you think
about trump essentially taking the fifth
to the new york attorney general
oh donald j trump jr yeah trump trump
senior previously said if you plead the
fifth it implies that you're guilty his
kids are now pleading the fifth so
make of that what you will i see a lot
of people in regular chat asking how to
get your message on the screen
to my left that is what we call youtube
super chat but don't worry i'm keeping
an eye on
regular youtube chat as well as twitch
chat dirty ricky subscribed for three
months
with prime and as you can see uh
became twitch subscriber 1310
which is nice craig says please debate
debate
gavin mcinnis the guy is now offering 10
million dollars to have you on his panel
i would take 10 million
yeah if somebody can get me a that offer
in writing
from gavin i'll send it to my
representation
uh shaner says do you know where these
speeches are taking place not sure where
these huge columns are
i think the columns is some place in
charlotte
and then melania i believe is expected
to
speak from the white house that's
what i recall being told
um oh people are saying check on
subscriptions
okay let me see we're still at 966 000.
yeah i mentioned at the top of the
stream that
while we are really in a race against
ourselves for a million youtube
subscribers
enlightened centrist i think pro-trump
centrist tim poole
did reach a million subscribers before
us making it all that much more
urgent that we uh that we get to a
million
we are now getting closer and closer to
what i would consider the bonafide
start of this event but we are not there
yet
trust me we're going to go to the the
important speeches momentarily
uh diddy miss asks how do you respond to
people who say that riots are taking
place in democrat cities and
thus are democrats fault i have already
recorded
a beautiful direct message on that exact
issue which will be part of our friday
podcast okay
so make sure you're subscribed to our
friday podcast
uh pablo swanson is back for the global
dunning-kruger festival
you and me both peace is a verb
says love you david keep up the great
work we're depending on it thank you
parrots pucks says 35 still will vote
trump
shake my head 35 oh my god way more than
35
trump will get at least 45 support i i
don't know of any way trump gets under
45 percent of the popular vote
d lars says much love pacman question
thoughts on zlavo zizek um
that's a longer that's a longer story
but i think that he's a fascinating
individual
certainly i think he won the debate with
jordan peterson by the way
our gonzales says can you explain and
brief your latino heritage yeah i was
born in argentina my family is
argentinian my first language was
spanish
and three of my four grandparents were
argentinian so
i'm argentinian and certainly based on
the census
um i am hispanic which is which is
exciting
i guess if you're a republican and
you're into identity politics it's an
exciting thing to be able to say
i guess do you guys want to listen to a
little bit of this or do you still want
to
wait on sort of like getting past the
propaganda videos what do people think
i'm kind of up for doing it either way
people want to hear a little bit of this
or people want to wait for now
seems like people are saying wait all
right let's just check in and see just a
little bit like just to get a flavor of
it the man that i arrested
you know several years before when i saw
the way that he
treated me fairly you know i saw the man
behind the suit
i started thinking man if that worked
for me
with this law enforcement officer how
can i
multiply this is like something you'd
see the during the dnc except completely
disingenuous
so that we can impact this on a larger
[Music]
scale
this is pretty aggressive weaponized
propaganda
so i think i've i've sort of heard
enough of it for the time being
thanks to karma pooptra oh my god
for subscribing with twitch prime as you
can see twitch subscriber 1313
which is a fantastic number um
oh people are asking about the kimberley
guilfoyle
north korean propaganda bit i'm willing
to show that yeah
uh actually that's on my twitter so that
one should be easy to find check this
out this is really wild
i like this theater who will rebuild the
promise of america
and ensure that every citizen can
realize their american dream
ladies and gentlemen leaders and
fighters for freedom
and liberty and the american dream the
best is yet
to come that is beautifully done
beautifully beautifully done so that was
excellent i really like that one that
one's a good one
what else do we have angela says i've
been looking forward to this stream all
day
worked at our local food bank today
served about 300 families
shout out to the flathead food bank in
kalispell montana love the show david
oh let's listen to what trump is saying
the streets and they were violent
streets
at the age of 38 he was arrested for
bank robbery
while john was in prison he began
reading the bible
and listening to christian radio oh my
god one day he heard reverend billy
graham on the radio proclaimed
jesus wants to be lord of your life on
that day
john dedicated his life to christ he
spent the rest of his time in prison
studying the bible when he was released
he heard a knock at his door
it was the officer who put him in jail
fbi special agent richard beasley who
said
i want you to know that i've been
praying for you now richard and john are
best friends
and we are grateful that richard is here
with us today
in the last 10 years since john was
released he has created one of the most
successful reentry programs
hoped for prisoners in las vegas i was
glad to speak there
earlier this year as john says
hope for prisoners is a movement that
began as a dream
in a tiny prison cell and is now making
a difference in the lives of thousands
truly bringing
hope that there is an opportunity and a
community that is waiting and willing to
offer them a second
chance john we honor your devotion to
showing returning citizens
that they are not forgotten we believe
that each person is made by god for a
purpose
i will continue to give all americans
including former inmates
the best chance to build a new life and
achieve their own
american dream and a great american
dream it is
now i'd like to ask john and richard to
say a few words i can't tell you
how grateful i am to have the
opportunity to speak here today
not so long ago this is gross guys just
so you know i'm not complicit in it he's
an avoiding the police not because of
anything that the police had done to me
personally
but due to the animosity i had allowed
to grow inside of me
making me believe that they were my
enemy but today
praise god i am filled with hope a proud
american citizen
who has been given a second chance my
transformation began in a prison cell
where i found myself a three-time
convicted felon
facing yet another sentence i gave my
life to jesus and made him a promise
that i would spend the rest guys i i
just can't do the religious propaganda
gave my life to i just i just can't do
it okay so i'm gonna i just want to hear
from you guys a little bit instead
um let's see who else we have here
sending in
messages um
if the dnc offered to have you speak
would you have done it
i mean i guess i'm not a democrat but
sure that seems like a huge opportunity
i don't can't imagine why they would ask
me to speak but i would have
scott phantasm says if the entire
republican party were gamers we'd have
world peace
okay a shield oh hold on that's no
message there grace lord
says morning from a wintry melbourne
australia what do you think it will take
for trump is to turn their backs on
their dear leader
if four years of nonsense hasn't changed
their minds i don't know what will
nothing will it's a waste of time to try
we just have to get turnout that's all
there's no point in arguing with these
people plexus says
buff david pakman meme i sent to twitter
at d pacman
if you can email them if you can email
me links through my website contact form
right now
i will get them up on the stream okay i
would love some of the buff david memes
and deep fakes
i didn't get them i honestly to be
totally frank
most times of day i can't even look at
my twitter replies feed because it's
just
it's it's constantly scrolling garbage
mostly
um not that you're sending me garbage
but it's it's useless there's just too
many messages coming in i just can't
it's it's
barely useful um and again i didn't say
send it via twitch i said send it via my
website
contact form a dominic senor
and sam talmage sends super chat sam
says
what are your thoughts on bob a bowie i
love it i love it i've been listening to
howard stern 20 years so i love it
marlon brimmer says david you and
destiny should have a weekly discussion
love the chemistry you two have yeah
i'd be up for doing something with
stephen kenneth destiny
bonnell the second aris sky retali
says it's time we all vote blue that's
true
um and uh oh there seems to be a glitch
with my super chats where they are
suddenly not
coming up like there's one about plasma
and it's not coming up okay so let me
turn the volume back up and i'm going to
deal with super chats just momentarily
here
what a great second chance i also
appreciate president trump's support for
law enforcement
i always felt like i had strong support
as an fbi agent but there's nothing
worse than knowing you're being second
guessed when you're doing your job
in certain parts of our country right
now law enforcement doesn't feel like
they have the support from their local
leaders
they're being painted with a broad brush
unfairly with calls for defunding
but as president trump knows this is
what we call a throwaway segment this is
total filler so i'll keep reading super
chats for now
seeley m town just subscribed via twitch
prime and says love the channel bezos
bucks for you
uh jeff in boston also subscribed i
appreciate that
um let's see here
uh where did i leave off
please vote powerfully okay here we are
uh joey two times says guilfoyle went
all by the power of gray skull
shield says from one hispanic person to
another what's your take on pineapple on
pizza so when i used to eat pork and
pork related products i would love
canadian bacon and and pineapple pizza
i've not eaten pork in probably eight
years at this point
and so now i don't see much use for
pineapple on pizza but from a moral
standpoint i'm not against it
body blasted says why don't you debate
like destiny your logic and knowledge
would be great to listen to my favorite
moments or when you dissect caller
arguments
we used to do way more debates and
honestly
it's a combination of so many fall
through
and we spend so much time on logistics
for nothing
and then a lot of them didn't actually
do well
that uh we just decided it wasn't worth
the time to set them up
let's go to rand paul here good evening
i'm senator rand paul from kentucky
donald trump and i met
many years ago before he was running for
anything oh god
when i first met him i recall being
struck by how down to earth he was
he seemed like just a normal guy okay a
normal guy with his own
plane and helicopter but who's counting
i was planning a medical mission trip to
guatemala to perform charity eye
surgeries
and we needed money to fund the trip
donald trump offered to help and
immediately came through for us
not only did he support my medical
mission to guatemala
but he also contributed to another
mission trip to haiti a year later
we performed hundreds of cataract
surgeries in both countries
nothing is more amazing than removing
the bandages from a person's eyes
and watching them as they see their
loved ones again
donald trump helped me make that happen
trump is responsible for ophthalmology
opponents both running for president we
all know how that turned out
but i'm proud of the job donald trump
has done as president
i don't always agree with him but our
occasional policy differences are far
outweighed by our significant agreements
but more important than simple agreement
is accomplishment
president trump gets things done like
what when some in congress wanted a
so-called
revenue neutral tax plan donald trump
and i
worked together to make sure that it was
a true
tax cut i brought president trump an
idea which
was not revenue neutral it exploded the
deficit just i'm sure you guys know that
plans donald trump overturned years of
red tape and bureaucrats
and he made it happen while others
talked about criminal justice reform
president trump actually signed the
first step
act the first real reform in a
generation
and one that sought to undo the harm
that others like joe biden have done
for those of us who lament the biden
crime bill that locked up a generation
of young black men
remember that biden bragged about a bill
that still wreaks havoc among people of
color
i'm supporting president trump because
he believes as i do
that's not true he's supporting him
because they play golf together fight
endless wars we must not continue to
leave our blood
and treasure in middle east quagmires
i flew with him to dover air force base
to honor two soldiers whose remains were
coming home from afghanistan
i'll never forget that evening i can
tell you the president
not only felt the pain of these families
but the president is committed to ending
this war
president trump is the first president
in a generation to seek to end war
rather than start one he intends to end
the war in afghanistan he is bringing
our men this is a great super chat
ophthalmologist rand paul doesn't
see trump's corruption it it does belie
credulity right
it's warfare i'm proud to finally see a
president
who agrees with that compare president
trump
with the disastrous record of joe biden
who has consistently called for more war
joe biden voted for the iraq war which
president trump has long called
the remember that of course that's not
true number one
the vote was to give a precedent
authorization now
it backfired and nobody should have
believed that it was merely
a theoretical vote that but joe biden
didn't vote for the war
number two trump is on record on the
howard stern show saying i would have
gone in
so the idea that trump you know now
however many years later trump is
against it in historical revisionism
afghanistan
to build their roads and bridges instead
of building them here at home
you need to support president trump for
another term
so to our soldiers and their families
join me
in supporting president trump to those
of you who want
lower taxes and better less expensive
health care
join me why don't we have that already
he's had four years
those of you who want to stand up and
fight the socialists
poisoning our schools remember there's
no risk of socialism in the united
states
fake enemy straw man let's rebuild
america together
wow ugly ugly but i mean not
obviously nearly as bad as kimberly
guilfoyle or don jr were but
still bad it just lies there were
probably
what do you guys think 40 lies during
that were there maybe 40 lies
i do have one deep fake buff david meme
to show you guys
just briefly um here it is
i guess it's called six pacman
it's kind of interesting uh that's me
after working on my lats
and growing a beard if anybody's not
seen it before
so yeah i don't know if there's any
music
there is not all right so there we go
that's one piece of uh
of memetic content let me refresh this
and see if we can get a better sync on
audio video because it wasn't
great uh during rand paul's
speech welcome to everybody just joining
us as we approach the top of the hour
we have just breached we've had a breach
of 10
000 viewers live on youtube and 2
000 viewers live on twitch appreciate
all 12 000 of you
quite frankly if 300 people were
watching uh
i'd be playing my drums right now to be
perfectly honest so it is not
uh it's because of you guys that i'm
here right now i appreciate that
um a few other people to thank
jessica torres is new member number five
on my website today
wendy wellman is new member number six
teresa stelter is number seven paul
spry is number eight and brendan sayer
is number nine uh you can
up the ante as you can see here we are
trying to reach yesterday's
yesterday's results were 56 so that's
where i've set
today's goal uh also thanks skarter
for the raid on twitch brought 173
viewers in and i very much appreciate
that that's what pushed us over 2000
so i love that zion is asking me
who is my favorite howard stern whack
packer so i really liked eric the actor
i i think beetlejuice is fantastic
the newer bigfoot i think is just
extraordinary and some of his
appearances
um with artie in the not so old days but
also not so recent
i think we're all uh really really great
seth barham says hey david have you seen
the they new ad from act dot tv it's a
parade of trump republicans
i'm sorry a parade of republicans from
2016 including pompeo
dunking on trump really well done i did
see it
and it's excellent let's listen to this
guy
it's near acadia national park where i
have over 200 years of family history
i have to confess i didn't support trump
in 2016.
skeptical that he shared my conservative
views i expected him to flip-flop on his
campaign promises
but he has followed through in his
promises including last week when he
brokered a deal to end
european union tariffs of eight percent
on maine live lobsters
and up to twenty percent on maine
lobster products it's all about
lobster women i live in an island with
370 residents
and lobstering is how we provide for our
families
maine's lobstermen are true
environmentalists i hope people
understand that this entire lobster
thing was concocted out of thin air i
mean it was just
uh it it it was summoned uh
like a spirit out of no i mean it's just
a completely
fabricated issue that donald trump has
put together but obama was against
lobsters
cater to environmental activists
although maine's lobstermen don't fish
there
obama's executive order offended us
greatly it's circumvented
the fisheries council's in you guys
heard that right
maine lobstermen don't fish in the
affected area but they were offended by
what barack obama did
this is conjured out like it's it's it's
like an evil spirit
president fishing families like mine
will have a voice
but if biden wins suspended he'll be
controlled by the environmental
extremist
i thought that being offended wasn't an
argument to these guys radical changes
that hurt our coastal communities
triggered i strongly support president
trump's re-election when he sees
something isn't right
he's fearless in fixing it he listens to
working people
he nominates judges who respect the
constitution
he keeps his word like eliminating the
european tariffs
and moving the u.s embassy from tel aviv
to jerusalem
i hope that's a huge issue i island
uh uh i lobster men who live on islands
are hugely keyed into where the israeli
embassy is i hope you guys understand
that
[Music]
good evening my name is chris peterson
my husband gary our family and i milk a
thousand cows on a dairy farm in
grantsburg wisconsin
a small middle american town truth be
told
until i married my cute farmer from
grantsburg a long time ago
i was a city slicker from minneapolis
which is about 70 miles south of us
donald trump became president in the
middle of the great depression for dairy
farmers
in wisconsin in 2016 prices were
horrible
and long time generational farms across
the nation were going out of business
in 2017 our 120 year old barn
which served as our milking center
caught fire and burned to the ground
our cows were spared but because they
needed to be milked three times a day
farmers friends and complete strangers
from all over northern wisconsin
helped haul them to other farms where
they stayed until we could rebuild
by the end of 2018 we had a new
state-of-the-art robotic milking
facility that
allows our cows to milk themselves three
times a day
at about the same time president trump's
economic boon began helping dairy
farmers across the nation
what boon was that president trump
understands
that farming is a complicated capital
intensive and risky business
more than any president in my lifetime
he has acknowledged
the importance of farmers and
agriculture
that support and focus on negotiating
new trade deals
gave us the confidence to rebuild our
barn and dairy operation
business was booming again and business
boomed right
until the kovid 19 shut down in march
many people probably don't realize that
our country is one of the few in the
world that produces nearly all of its
own food
fewer still understand how close our
food production
and distribution system came to
collapsing this past spring
but president trump understood and again
took steps to provide the supports we
needed
president trump this seems like a nice
lady and everything
but like who are these speakers
a lobster guy who was offended by obama
a woman
on self milking cow technology i mean
this is like
they expanded from two to two and a half
hours
but for for this i mean it's a little
weird
[Music]
what was happening prior to president
trump you had businesses that were
over-regulated all right yeah these two
were horrible yesterday so we're going
to mute them
thanks to jack's lantern as well as one
dimensional double 07 for subscribing on
twitch
uh both of you uh you are now
subscribers 1318
and 1319 as you can see up there
uh captain flank says i'm surprised this
lady didn't blame her barn on obama
everything's obama's fault in this uh in
this convention
grace lord says is she amnesiac or is
she a lot younger than she looks jimmy
carter was a farmer
yes peanut farmer indeed what i would
love to see is someone who could come on
and give us a
reasonable explanation as to why donald
trump stands
hinging forward at the waist and if it's
lifts just tell us that it's lifts that
would be
way more informative than you know an
offended lobsterman
or cows that milk themselves yeah this
people are pointing out this could have
been one if you cut down
all of this stuff to just the core
material like what we mean is the
lunatic speeches like kimberly guilfoyle
you could have knocked it out in two
hours you don't you really didn't need
four nights there's no doubt about that
um let's see
lance smith says michael cohen has an ad
against donald trump
he also announced today he's going to be
on with rachel maddow which i think is
going to be
extremely interesting extremely
interesting and i'm looking forward to
that
very strongly um
joe grober the effing game cat says i
should be mispronouncing hispanic as
hispanic yeah i've heard trump
mispronounce it that way and it's weird
it's really weird
uh carl says do you think lobsters are
his
main issue very clever very clever we're
going to puns
with getrick says lobsters when are we
going to talk about toilets
i'm actually hoping that donald trump
will make
the 10 to 15 flush events
that he refers to a key part of his
thursday night speech
i want to figure out why it is that
donald trump finds himself needing to
flush the toilet 10 to 15 times that's
nothing i've ever
even heard of happening um so hopefully
that'll that'll be a factor
dong johnson says self minking
technology self milking technology is my
kind of opportunity zone
bronx bjorn says this convention is a
case study in cognitive dissonance and
false consciousness
yeah a burning rangers gaming channel
says trump hasn't done jack for
wisconsin dairy farmers generational
farmers in the state have still been
going out of business at historic levels
in the past four years that is accurate
let's go to larry kudlow and see if he's
been drinking
years ago i worked for ronald reagan you
know i work for ronald reagan
more recently i helped the team craft
donald trump's
economic plan during the campaign it was
a roaring success
inheriting a stagnant economy on the
front end of recession
he doesn't seem drunk program of tax
cuts historic rollback of onerous
regulations that crippled small business
unleashing energy to become the world's
number one producer
and free fair and reciprocal trade deals
to bolster manufacturing agriculture
technology
and other sectors the economy was
rebuilt
in three years unemployment fell to the
lowest rate of 3.5 percent
blue colors african americans hispanics
women
all groups benefited enormously everyone
was better off
a rising tide lifted all boats
then came a once in 100 year pandemic
it was awful health and economic impacts
were tragic cuddler looks like the guy
that could get you a great deal on term
life insurance as long as you lie about
whether you're a smoker
and effectively with an extraordinary
rescue for health and safety
to successfully fight the covet virus a
great bipartisan rescue also saved the
economy
right now our economic health is coming
back
with emergency spending and tax cuts
americans
are going back to work there's a housing
boom
there's an auto boom a manufacturing
boom
a consumer spending boom stocks are in
record territory
a v-shaped recovery is pointing to
better than 20
growth in the second half of this year
now looking ahead more tax cuts and
regulatory rollback will be in store
payroll tax cuts for higher wages income
tax cuts for the middle class
capital gains tax cuts for investment
productivity
and jobs much more regulatory relief for
small businesses
remember this is the same promise that
they made in 2016. they've had four
years
and they're running on the exact same
stuff because they haven't done any of
it
deep pandemic who in their right mind
would pick the pockets of taxpayers and
drain money from their wallets and
purses look our economic choice is very
clear
do you want economic health prosperity
opportunity and optimism or do you want
to turn back
to the dark days of stagnation recession
and pessimism i believe there can't be
better economic policies than we've had
in recent years
so i say stay with them thank you
wow moving inspirational speech
who's this guy i'm john peterson
owner of a second generation metal
fabrication business called
shooty metals we've been stamping our
products and services
made in the usa since 1957.
okay i'm gonna mute this guy again my
commitment has been mostly to cover
like the main speeches the the people
that we know um and i wanna hear from
you guys
this is a great opportunity to get your
super chats in if you're one of the uh
nearly eleven thousand folks uh watching
on youtube
those will pop up on the screen to my
left grace lord asks do you like
polluted rivers
lead in your water how about an oil
spill in your backyard then vote trump
and republican today
well said well said um
marlena harris says so are they just not
going to talk about the
virus basically they'll talk about it
only in the context of saying trump has
done the best of everything on it that's
the con
context jarrett round says environmental
extremists that one guy said
great job in pog champs yesterday by the
way you played well i played okay
um okay milo k
says here's a challenge it's our first
challenge of the evening
if you hit 967 000 subscribers
in the next two minutes that would be by
9 10 i will make another donation to the
biden campaign hashtag
biden2020. we're 663 away
from 967. there's 11 000 people watching
we should be able to do that to secure
milo's challenge um
967 yeah we're only about 650 away so
that should certainly be doable i'll
check back in on that in two minutes
um oh my friend brian coldy is here
uh my my
sort of like my brother-in-law twice
removed by marriage it's very indirect
where do they find these people to speak
at these events the bs they talk about
is crazy
by the way we need more members join up
indeed colby that is a beautiful message
so let's see
crystal syrette is new member number 10
george megalanez is new member number
11.
andy malloy is number 12 russell clemons
is number 13
david lazarus is number 14. so there it
is coldy that's just for you
14 people just signed up uh
which is amazing amazing
um let's see
peter orbach is here peter a longtime
supporter
says they're all nuts you're great cc
please
people want closed captions i guess i
could do some closed captions sometimes
people get distracted by them
oh they're not even on screen that's not
good hold on let me see if i can adjust
this
how's that so now we actually have is
that does that bother anybody that i've
made the screen just marginally smaller
so we can see the closed captions
okay um mr herrera says you missed my
super chat scroll up yeah they're coming
in so fast
it is not guaranteed that i'm going to
get to your super chat
but i guess if you send me one okay here
it is mr herrera says i think he's
trying to secure the rural vote
certainly yeah and that's that's a play
that's a play grace lee says hello from
montana we didn't get hit by the virus
until june so nobody takes it seriously
here a co-worker is a widow now
blames obama surreal that is crazy
that is crazy we had a challenge from
milo to get to 967
000 subscribers in two minutes we failed
but here is someone graham lynch
and i'm honored to speak to you tonight
about something that
so important to all of us our faith
as americans we know the first line of
the first amendment
protects our freedom of religion but
what we often forget the actual words
are free exercise of religion
that means living out our faith in our
daily lives
and our schools and our jobs and yes
even in the public square our founders
did not envision a
quiet hidden faith they fought to ensure
that the voices of
faith were always welcomed what is this
not silenced
not bullied but during the obama biden
administration
these freedoms were under attack
democrats tried to make faith
organizations pay for abortion inducing
drugs
democrats tried to force it understand
that that's not true
what what it was going to be was that
insurance would cover without a co-pay
oh my i mean i can't even do it guys
this is so stupid
those are the facts but then
we the people elected donald trump
people of faith suddenly had a fierce
advocate in the white house
he appointed judges who respect the
first amendment by the way the morning
after pill is not an abortion i i i
skipped over that completely because
it's so idiotic trees would not be
forced to violate
their beliefs he withdrew the policies
that placed our little girls at risk
and on the world stage president trump
became the first president
to talk about the importance of
religious freedom at the united
nations giving hope to people
faith around the world in america we
have not yet experienced physical
persecution
even though the left has tried to
silence us
even during the pandemic we saw how
quickly life can change
some democratic leaders tried to ban
church services
while marijuana shops and abortion
clinics were declared essential
but you know what truly is essential our
right to worship freely
and live our faith in every aspect of
life
the biden harris vision for america
leaves no room
for people of faith biden is more
religious than trump mr
football coach they will force the
choice between being obedient to god
or to caesar because the radical left
god
is government power so in the words of
my grandfather
billy graham oh god let us stand for
political freedom
moral freedom religious freedom and the
rights of all americans
and let's never give in to those who
would attempt to take it from us
tonight i'm proudly standing in that
public square
and i hope and pray you will join me
in voting to re-elect president trump
let's hope not
i guess we'll figure out if prayer works
soon huh
i am bob lesolovich mayor of evlett a
small town in the iron range of
minnesota all right
father and grandfather earn their
livings mining the raw materials that
made this we're going to put a pause on
bob for a little bit just so we can
recover
um thank you to mers pat
robin your rhubarb mozilla
and it tramwell as well as stellamont
and grab it and grizzcernwit
and slingblade for uh subscribing over
on twitch
um mitchell easton yeah she i guess she
is related to billy graham i don't
imagine she would lie about that
um oliver wilde says oh aoc was right
elephants deserve better
than the gop gilgamesh says look at us
lie about lobsters and cows while we tap
dance on 176 000 american graves it's
like 182 000 now
political key jiggling for short
attention spanned bootlickers
yeah kevin delos says have you heard of
charles
hurt charles herbster works for trump
he's an angus breeder
that i use his bulls but has he done
anything for us farmers
i've heard the name don't know much
about him
uh yeah the super chats continue to come
in beautifully
sean says we could probably do something
more productive during this rank the
fast and furious movies or something
i saw the first one and the second one
the first one was better
that's my ranking chakaseki says hey
dave could you give a shout out to
elissa from nyc she's a new viewer
welcome melissa
great to have you here and uh look
forward to
continued quirky quips
from chaka seki edo says usps plus the
closing pole gap scares me can joe biden
win
yes he can win but we must overwhelm the
vote
that's the reality we must overwhelm the
vote that's the only way
because they've got a lot of shenanigans
up their sleeves
and i've got a story coming up about
that
tomorrow and we're going to discuss that
tomorrow
milo says it's okay i will donate to
biden anyway i'm so embarrassed milo
milo challenged us to see if we could
get to 967
000 subscribers on youtube we were only
600 away
when milo issued the challenge and
we only got like a hundred people to do
it
i i apologize milo i'm ashamed
uh personally i'm i'm sorry maybe we'll
get some other challenges in via super
chat
okay next speaker coming up this is
someone my name is abby johnson
and i spent eight years working for
planned parenthood
but today oh no i'm a pro-life activist
i've heard about her
in college planned parenthood approached
me at a volunteer fair
they talked about helping women in
crisis and their commitment to keep
abortion
safe legal and rare i was convinced to
volunteer and later offered a full-time
job as a medical assistant
before my promotion to director of the
clinic
i truly believed i was helping women
this actually seems like a weird choice
because the country is more in favor
than at any point since roe v weighed in
abortions being legal most of the time
so i'm a bit surprised that they would
go hard on abortion i mean i know that
it's a it's an issue you can raise money
on but it i'm not sure that it's the
right issue from a voting standpoint
assist who believed in eugenics her goal
when founding planned parenthood was to
eradicate
the minority population today almost
80 percent of planned parenthood
abortion facilities are strategically
located in minority neighborhoods
and every year planned parenthood
celebrates
its racist roots by presenting the
margaret
sanger award later in august my
supervisor assigned me
a new quota to meet an abortion quota
i was expected to sell double the
abortions performed
the previous year when i push back
underscoring
planned parenthood's public-facing goal
of decreasing abortions i was
reprimanded
and told abortion is how we make
our money but the tipping point came a
month later
when a physician asked me to assist with
an ultrasound guided
abortion nothing prepared me
for what i saw on the screen an
unborn baby fighting back desperate
to move away from the suction oh my god
i'll never forget what the doctor said
next
this is like vile vile propaganda
and you know the thing that is really
dishonest about this
is you know there's a lot of medical
procedures that if described in detail
many of us wouldn't love the description
of it
that's a different questions from from
whether something should be legal
and whether old white republican men
should get to decide on what's legal and
that's the game that they play i hope
people understand that
it seems like people uh in the chat
do understand that um
okay maybe some of you don't but it
seems most people most people do uh
do do understand that this is crazy
this is actually just straight up crazy
um but i guess it's still marginally
less crazy than guilfoyle right to some
degree i don't know
uh mark davis says when i was a
christian i was thought to tr to pray in
silence
privately otherwise it's grandstanding
and for show
you're not the only person who's
religious who has told me that
or who was religious
um sean tedrow
astutely points out pro-life 150 000
dead yeah
yes and trump's saying it is what it is
180 000 dead trump asked about it says
it is what it is to uh jonathan swann
okay people want to hear a little bit
more of this drivel
for global health groups that promote
abortion that same year he overturned an
obama biden rule
that allowed government subsidy of
abortion he appointed a record number of
pro-life judges including two supreme
court justices
and importantly he announced a new rule
protecting the rights of health care
workers objecting to abortion
many of whom i work with every day
life is a core tenant of who we are as
americans
and this election is a choice between
two
radical anti-life activists and the most
pro-life president we have ever had
remember joe biden's more religious than
trump due to
action go door-to-door make calls
talk to your neighbors and friends and
vote
on november 3rd take action that
reelects our president and do it with
our
very most vulnerable americans in mind
the ones who haven't been born yet
[Music]
really horrible i mean just truly truly
horrible thanks to big
puffy cake for subscribing on twitch
with the message thank you jeff bezos
for the prime subscription
uh oh it looks like they're going to
bring out one of the covington kids
it looks like they're going to do it
which is crazy
really really crazy steve beltrano
says this is so disgustingly
disingenuous that it literally makes me
nauseous
i'm only somewhat more enthused about
the biden campaign
listen i i understand what you're saying
but i think the differences at this
point are
dramatic these are dramatic dramatic
differences this kid is about to speak
okay so i hope everybody's ready
i want to say thanks to don lynch who's
new member number 15 on my website today
nicholas collard is new member number
16.
shelly pint is new member number 17
and darius strassel is new member number
18.
sorry i don't want to miss mark mata who
is number 19
and abigail mckellar new member number
20 at joinedpakman.com the
the reason we're looking at 56 is
because that was yesterday's number
on the steps of the lincoln memorial
last year
before i begin i'd like to thank
president trump for the opportunity to
share some of my story
and why it matters so much to this
november's election sounds like there's
a dinner going on in the background
march for life in washington dc where i
demonstrated in defense of the unborn
later that day i bought a make america
great again hat
because our president donald trump has
distinguished himself as one of the most
pro-life presidents
in the history of our country oh my god
and i wanted to express my support for
him too
nauseating looking back now how could i
possibly imagine
that the simple act of putting on that
red hat
would unleash hate from the left and
make myself the target of network
and cable news networks nationwide being
from kentucky
the birthplace of abraham lincoln my
classmates and i visited the lincoln
memorial
i found myself face to face with nathan
phillips
and other professional protesters
looking to turn me
into the latest poster child showing why
trump is bad
well the media portrayed me as an
aggressor with a relentless
smirk on my face in reality the video
confirms i was standing with my hands
behind my back
and an awkward smile on my face that hid
two thoughts
one don't do anything that might further
agitate the man banging a drum in my
face
and two i was trying to follow a family
friend's advice
never to do anything to embarrass your
family your school
or your community before i knew what was
happening it was over
one of mr phillips fellow agitators
yelled out
we got him it's all right here on video
and we won grandpa what i thought was a
strange
encounter quickly developed into a major
news story
complete with video footage my life
changed forever in that one moment
the full war machine of the mainstream
media revved up into attack mode
the what they did so without researching
the full video of the incident
without ever investigating mr phillips
motives
or without ever asking me for my side of
the story
and do you know why because the truth
was not important advancing their
anti-christian
anti-conservative anti-donald trump
narrative was all that mattered
and if advancing their narrative ruin
the reputation
and future of the teenager from
covington kentucky
well so be it covington that would teach
him not to wear a mega hat
i learned what was happening to me had a
name
it was called being canceled as in a no
as in revoked they're going void
cancelled is what's happening to people
around this country who refuse to be
silenced by the far left
many are being fired humiliated or even
threatened
and often the media is a willing
participant
but i would not be canceled i fought
back hard to expose the media for what
they did to me
and i won a personal victory while much
more must be done
i look forward to the day that the media
returns to providing balanced
responsible and accountable news
coverage i know president trump hopes
for that too
and i know you'll agree with me when we
say that no one in this country
has been a victim of unfair media
coverage more than president donald
trump
in november i believe this country must
unite
around a president who calls the media
out and refuses to allow them to create
a narrative
instead of reporting the facts i believe
we must join a president who will
challenge the media to return to
objective journalism
and together i believe we must all
embrace our first amendment rights
and not hide in fear of the media
inspiring from the tech companies
or from the outraged mob either this
is worth fighting for this is worth
voting for
and this is what donald trump stands for
thank you all for listening to me
tonight and one more thing
let's make america great again
wow what a defiant principled message to
people who are already voting for donald
trump
um okay here is
who's this i don't know it's somebody
i'm pam bondi oh our party's themed
tonight
i didn't even recognize her land devops
remember when she stopped investigating
trump when he handed her cash
reason deliverance you can't help but be
proud
to call this country home but for joe
biden
it's been the land of opportunism not
opportunity as a career prosecutor and
former attorney general of florida
i fought corruption and i know what it
looks like
whether it's done by people wearing
trump literally donated to her and the
investigation into trump university
disappeared she fought corruption she
this is beyond parody look at joe biden
as the model of integrity
but when you look at his 47-year career
in politics
the people who benefited are his family
members
not the american people let's take a
closer look
we all know about joe's son hunter biden
a corrupt ukrainian oligarch
put hunter on the board of his gas
company even though he had no experience
in ukraine
or in the energy sector none yet he was
paid
millions to do
nothing he only had one qualification
that mattered
he was the son of the man in charge of
distributing usaid to ukraine
and recently reported information
revealed that a few months
after hunter biden joined that corrupt
company's board
the obama biden state department began
doing
business with them even when it remained
under investigation for corruption
and it gets worse that very same company
was being
investigated by a ukrainian prosecutor
joe biden the vice president of the
united states
threatened to withhold aid to ukraine
trump's charity was found to have been
using the
donations as a slush fund she took money
from trump and stopped investigating him
and she's coming up and talking about
biden
his campaign for president
now let's talk about china fact
joe biden flew to china on air force two
with hunter along for the ride
they said he was just there as a family
member but we know
that's untrue in beijing hunter didn't
just go sightseeing
he had meetings with his chinese bank
partners
hunter even arranged for his dad to meet
with one of the partners
ten days later those chinese communist
bankers
approved millions to go to hunter's firm
honestly is this a voting issue in the
sense that trump's way more corrupt
and people still vote for him so like
would this swing any votes
even if her claims were true virus
to this day hunter controls a 10
stake in that firm and joe biden's done
more than look the other way on china
he said the chinese aren't our
competition
come on man they're not bad folks
come on joe okay talk to the folks in
middle america
who lost countless jobs to china while
your son was getting rich with them
but there's more fact there have been
numerous press reports that have shown
other close
biden family members benefited from
joe's 47
year political trump's entire presidency
is lining the pockets of his
he and his family how is how is this a
viable attack line
i guess if people are idiots only houses
in iraq
joe biden's close family member who you
guessed it
had no experience in the industry and no
experience in iraq
a company official bragged that it helps
to have a family member the vice
president as partner
the family member put it more bluntly by
saying
there's a line of 747s
filled with cash ready to invest
now let's follow the money down south
again as reported in the press
yet another close family member of joe's
set his sights on costa rica and jamaica
where millions of dollars flowed from
the obama biden administration
in taxpayer back loans i don't think
these attacks are going to land
first of all it's too complicated the
people they need to appeal to don't
really understand something this you
know costa rica they're just not going
to i don't think this is going to land
of conduct
and that's just what he did as vice
president
imagine all right this stream is not
going super well so let's switch over to
this one
president how many american families
would be allowed to get away with this
why should there be one standard for the
elite political class
and another set of rules for the rest of
us
when millions of americans voted for
donald trump
they knew he'd be different and he is
he's a tough no-nonsense outsider
who can't be bought or intimidated he
won't even take a paycheck
from the american people he donates his
paycheck to charities
across this country democrats have been
lecturing america about integrity for
four years while their nominee has been
writing the textbook
on abuse of power for 40 years
if they want to make this election a
choice between who's saving america
and who's swindling america bring it on
joe says he'll build back better yeah
build the bidens back better our
president is in this to build
a safer better and stronger america
and he will finish what he started
to keep this a real land of opportunity
for everyone why didn't he even start
why hasn't he done any of it yet
secure your ballot or register to vote
text vote to 88022
remember the best is yet to come
okay pam bondi who famously ended an
investigation into trump university as
a.g in florida
when trump donated i believe it was 25
grand
to her campaign for reelection she
talked to us about
fighting corruption if you can believe
that
super chats are flowing in i love
hearing from folks
uh i believe that we oh oh i want to
hear this these little like
these pre-recorded trump things are wild
you're what you've got
70 80 years on this earth what are you
gonna do with it
are you gonna make that difference are
you gonna say i was there
sorry i thought it was an actual trump
thing where he shows how out of touch he
is it's not
okay super chats are coming in tom
miller says strange strategy having pam
bondi calling hunter biden unqualified
right before trump's children speak any
moment now
beautifully said beautifully said austin
becker says wasn't trump pro-choice for
a long time
of course yeah when trump was when trump
was 68 years old he met a kid he liked
and was like you know i'm glad that kid
wasn't aborted
i'm now against abortion like that's the
story trump tells
that we're supposed to believe as to how
it's 68 he decided he's no longer in
favor of abortion
dave wampler says words per minute very
low in these speeches yeah there's a
reason for that
there's a reason for that benefit or uh
yeah benefit says pam is a wacko but i
would still marry her
okay i guess some people want to hear
from kimberly
gilfoy because she's so bonkers but no
it's it's just it
it's not really a it's just a super cut
sort of thing
um peter orbach says david the rnc is
just seeing how much they can get away
with this election they don't care about
democracy at all this time it's an
experiment
your guess is as good as mine chef's
pawn says at least this time pam bondi
is more well prepared with a written
speech than trying to talk off the top
of her head like she did at the
impeachment
that was really bad i don't know how
many of you saw that but that was really
bad
thanks to ambrose breton and
sanity who are subscribers 1333
and 1334 uh
on twitch which i very much appreciate
also want to say thanks to karen
sweeney who is new member number 21
at joinpacman.com we do have a coupon
code 2020 now which just
chops 66 percent right off of
memberships
and we have a goal of 56 just because
that's the number we got to yesterday
nothing special about the number 56
um okay
i am having that weird problem where the
super chats aren't updating on screen so
let's put the audio back up and i'm
going to deal with that powerful
influence and authority
president trump has proven that when the
stakes are highest
he is proud to entrust many of our
nation's most crucial jobs
to women the number of dedicated
amazing brilliant relentless women that
are dedicated to the country and to the
president
and to preserving the american dream is
one of the greatest if not the greatest
things i'll ever be a part of
all right super chats are back back
megan whitfield
says i left this as a voicemail but i'd
like to bring it up now how many
deplorables are out there hiding in the
wings and identify
as the silent majority are we worried
about that
unpredictable here's tiffany trump trump
since speaking at the republican
convention
four years ago so much has changed for
the world
for our country and for my family like
so many students across the world
i graduated from law school during the
pandemic
our generation is unified in the facing
the future in uncertain times and many
of us
are considering what kind of country we
want to live in
as a recent graduate i can relate to so
many of you
who might be looking for a job my father
built a thriving economy once
and believe me he will do it again
this election i urge each and every one
of you
to transcend political boundaries this
she's super relatable right guys freedom
versus oppression
for opportunity versus stagnation a
fight to keep america
true to america i urge you to make
judgment
based on results and not rhetoric if you
believe
in criminal justice reform there is only
one president
that passed the first theft act giving
people a second chance
a chance at a life once again and
if you believe in expanding quality and
affordable health
care only president trump my father
signed the right to try into law the
favored nations clause
and other actions to lower drug prices
and keep americans
from getting ripped off people must
recognize
that our thoughts our opinions and even
the choice of who we are
voting for may and are being manipulated
and visibly coerced by the media and
tech giants
if you tune in no mention a foreign
interference opinion or another
and what you share if it does not fit
into the narrative that they seek to
promote
then it is either ignored or deemed a
lie
regardless of the truth this
manipulation
of what information we receive impedes
our freedoms
rather than allowing americans the right
to form our own beliefs
this misinformation system keeps people
mentally enslaved to the ideas they deem
correct
this has fostered unnecessary fear and
divisiveness amongst us
why are so many in media and technology
and even in our own government so
invested in promoting
a biased and fabricated view
ask yourselves why are we prevented from
seeing certain information
why is one viewpoint promoted while
others are hidden
this is sort of the argument where like
any time we have an
adult conversation about climate science
you have to let some whack job in you
know
that this is exactly how they justify
that every view anybody who wants to be
heard must be heard on equal footing
on corporate media anytime some right
wing nut
demands to speak at a college they must
be allowed or it's discrimination and
censorship this is how they get to that
students with contrary opinions are too
afraid to speak
many students find themselves
suppressing their beliefs to fit into
what
the acceptable group think is in short
our nation suffers by inhibiting our
diversity of thought
and inclusion of ideas working together
outside of our political comfort zones
we'll accomplish
so much more some cynical politicians
do not seem to believe in the miracle of
america
well i do as maximal alvarez said so
eloquently
last night if freedom is lost in this
country
there is nowhere else to go
having hope is not weakness and
believing in miracles
is a gift from god so tonight
i want to tell you the uncensored truth
of what we believe in
we believe in equality of opportunity
we believe in freedom of thought and
expression
think what you want seek out the truth
learn from those with different opinions
and then freely
make your voice heard to the world we
believe in school choice because a child
zip code in america
should not determine their future that's
code for defund public schools everybody
for all faiths and we believe
in the american spirit a country founded
on ideas
not identity a country where our
differences are embraced
and the only country where the word
dream has been attached to it
because in america your life
is yours to chart so if you're hearing
these things
and thinking to yourself that is the
kind of country that i want to live in
well whether you're really it's sort of
a less crazy but equally wrong version
of the guilfoyle speech if you actually
listen to the arguments
as so many other politicians employ they
mask
themselves in disguises of decency as
they try to pressure us
to mask our own identities and beliefs
my father is the only person to
challenge the establishment
the entrenched bureaucracy big pharma
and media monopolies to ensure that
americans constitutional freedoms are
upheld
and that justice and truth prevail my
father
does not run away from challenges even
in the face of outright hatred
because fighting for america is
something he will sacrifice
anything for he dreams big dreams for
our country
and he is relentless at achieving them
you see
make america great again is not a slogan
for my father it is what drives him to
keep his promise
of doing what is right for american
citizens
the energy of change and opportunity
is with us god has blessed us with
unstoppable spirit
his spirit the american spirit my dad
has proven to be driven by that spirit
he has demonstrated his faith in his
uncompromising heart
and actions my father has made me
believe that america
can truly be great again
if you care about living your life
without restraints
about rebelling against those who would
suppress your voice
and building your american dream then
the choice in this election is clear
a vote for my father donald j trump
is a vote to uphold our american ideals
be true to yourself and stay true to the
dream of america
thank you and god bless you all
all right so we're gonna have a parade
of trumps coming in today
um okay here's kim reynolds the governor
of iowa we're gonna skip this one at
least for the time being
a lot of people very much reacting to
tiffany trump
um francisco resto says everyone so far
sounds fake it's so cringe
you know a lot of comments about her
physical appearance i don't think that
that's
really super relevant you know bronx
says i didn't hear a word she said too
busy focusing on all the nip and tuck
yeah you know i mean it's like you know
uh the the physical appearance stuff
doesn't it's not where i would
necessarily focus
david goris says apparently her speech
will also state that the holy spirit is
the american spirit that her dad
embodies
yeah that that's how they see trump as a
pseudo-deity
um i don't know that his kids really do
i mean they're saying it but
anyway uh john hagan says the entire
world is scared
that trump will win four more years i'm
guessing you are norwegian given the
currency the norwegian kroner
yes i'm getting messages daily from
people all over the world
i got messages from canadians today
and belgians and all sorts of different
folks
all over the world um
shelby coke says happy that tiffany got
the chance to speak so she could stay in
the will
truly the american dream yeah as far as
i knew trump and tiffany didn't get
along well but she was there you know
who knows what what's going on behind
the scenes
a coordinate coordinate says not a
single word about her relationship with
her father suspicious oh well there
that goes to my point again who cares
but ren holder says who's writing these
speeches and why are they so evil
kyle downey says they're going slow to
calm the crazy last night
it does seem like they've decided to
just do kind of like a more
boring uh evening
and maybe it is uh part of par
part of some deliberate plan i mean a
lot of these were planned in advance so
it may or may not be the case i don't
know super guy says i guarantee you
trump had to pay
tiffany to speak yeah so a lot of people
seem to think that there was something
not particularly genuine about that
tiffany trump
speech um melania trump speaking i
believe
at 20 past the hour so we're i think
about 35 minutes
from melania trump's speech
um a few other people i want to thank
before i fall too far behind
xenon schmidt is new member number 22
today
a t is new member number 23 joseph
hernandez is number 24
and judy warren is new member number 25
that's uh
almost halfway that's great um
let's see social anxiety says my dad is
god
my god is dad
colin mcmorrow asks what the hell did we
just watch
that's not an unusual sentiment
after night one and what we've seen so
far of night two
jamie says that this is mind-numbing
matt asks how much was added to her
trust fund for that
um a lot of suspicion that that was not
genuine a lot a lot of suspicion
and i don't totally disagree with people
from what we know but i really don't
care
i mean whether she gets along with trump
or not she's wrong that we should
re-elect trump
right that's that's the important piece
and that's all i can say
psy borgren has just gifted a twitch
subscription which puts us now one away
from the very coveted
three subscriber seven very very close
to one three three seven much coveted
uh it is unclear who it is that is going
to achieve that
um but i know that that is often when we
get to it
and it is cravens14
who is number one three three seven
let's listen to mike pence
because of who we are and because of
what we are
a country where a boy born into poverty
in a log cabin
raised right here on the frontier of
indiana could educate himself
become a lawyer become a president of
the united states who would preserve the
union
abolish slavery and save the nation
[Music]
as a fellow hoosier visiting lincoln's
boyhood home has
always been a treasured experience for
me and my family
it's a place that made lincoln it shaped
lincoln
and defined the man that lincoln would
become
america is the land of opportunity
as president donald trump declared at
mount rushmore and grab a refill wipe
while pence talks be anything and
together
we can achieve anything every day
president donald trump is fighting to
protect the promise of american liberty
every day our president's been fighting
to expand the reach of the american
dream
and on every single day without fail
president donald trump has been fighting
for you
so tonight i'd like to introduce you to
a few remarkable americans
who represent that solemn pledge
who embody our president's unbreakable
devotion to ensuring that america
is a land of unlimited opportunity for
all
jack is an eight-year-old from wisconsin
who was struggling academically and
socially in school with jack's mom sarah
who works three jobs to support her son
applied for wisconsin's school
choice voucher program we're glad that
we were able to get the school choice
voucher to go to that school with jack
he would have slipped through the cracks
in public schools
and having the option to go to a school
that fits
him has been a real game changer for us
and i know that because of that
opportunity that
he's going to succeed and he's going to
achieve that goal of being an apparatus
engineer if that's what he
chooses to stick with laura mclin
is a mother of another inspiring boy
jordan
jordan has duchenne muscular dystrophy a
fatal muscle weakening disorder
jordan was at my side in indiana when as
governor i
signed a law allowing terminally ill
patients to access
experimental drugs not yet approved by
the fda
in 2018 president trump signed the
landmark federal
right to try bill into law thanks to the
president's leadership
critically ill patients have the right
to access
life-saving experimental treatments we
started fighting for right to try which
basically says if you have a terminal
illness
and there's a drug that exists and you
don't qualify for the clinical trial
there's no other way to receive it
this is a unique pathway that allows you
to have access
you made us a promise back in indiana
that you would do whatever
it took to help jordan and we're so
grateful that you joined us on this
journey
and stuck it out until it became law so
that other people
could access treatments so jordan if
president trump was standing right there
what would you say to him today about
right to try
thank you for being a hero to everybody
in the country
judge cheryl allen made history in 2007
when she became the first
african-american woman to be elected to
serve on the pennsylvania superior court
it's because of leaders like judge allen
that our nation has overcome our
greatest challenges in this time
of uh racial division in the country
do you see faith and values and
the strong stand that president trump
has taken for equality of opportunity
as a pathway toward bringing the country
together
as a senior citizen i'll leave it at
that
i know what racism feels like but i also
know
that but for my being
in this country i would have never been
able to achieve
[Music]
the things that i have been able to
achieve there are
injustices but the way to deal with
those
injustices is for people to sit down
across the table and talk and come up
with solutions
i do believe that president trump is
committed to that
in 2016 i have to confess that
i really did not know candidate trump at
the time
but i have to say that he really won me
over
gino is a truck driver from ohio who
heard politicians for years make empty
promises about defending american jobs
only to see those promises broken again
and again
and in 2019 when general motors closed
its plan in lordstown ohio
president donald trump refused to stand
by and watch it happen
and as gino observed this president
reached out to general motors
to find a way to bring jobs back to
lordstown
and plans were soon set into motion to
create
lordstown motors president trump says
this is how we fix it
and i thought well that's a simple
solution there's no other president
there's no one that has even tried to do
it president trump's a doer
he appreciates every one of us and i
know he does i've seen it
when he said make america great again
that was his task
that wasn't that wasn't his slogan that
was his task
and every hat you see that says mega on
it that's what your president's doing
for you
thank you mr president for keeping the
promises that you made
and then there's pastor aaron johnson
today he's the executive director of the
tulsa dream center
a non-profit that provides education and
medical services and food to those in
need
aj you've got a great personal story
when you see the way
this president this administration has
been leaning in
to create opportunities investments in
communities around the country to create
jobs
expanding educational choice what what
does that mean to the families that you
serve every day
it means so much to our families i did
grow up in a single parent home and so
we serve over 600 boys and girls right
now on a daily basis even in covet
and so for us to give these moms to have
an opportunity
to take more money on their check on
their paycheck home back to them
to have their children be able to go all
right i'm back are we getting to the
identity politics part of the evening
yet
so much to us there's been so much
greater opportunity for individuals
to come together in any walk of life
people have really been able to see such
a positive change
and been filled with hope especially
throughout this time
lydia this is really bad i'm not i'm
gonna yeah the whole segment is really
bad
um okay what are people saying kyle
hopper says
injecting bleach if this pen spits much
longer
that's a good one um sean quillin says
mother won't approve of him being so
close to that woman yeah
mike mike pence has to be chaperoned
oliver wilde says it's telling that
according to today's republican party
the last remarkable republican president
lincoln was born two centuries ago we
agree
yeah it's interesting how there's no
mention of bush and of course there's no
chance bush is going to show up
because bush i don't think is actually
voting for donald trump it seems pretty
clear that he's not
uh let's see what else we've got going
on today
wow a lot of craziness happening um
in youtube chat twitch chat respectful
tonight although some people did get
banned before we
we even got started a lot of people
worried about
mother sean quill and does mother know
he's out past his bedtime
dive down says i quote abc the math is
simple if donald trump wins the same
states he won four years ago
he'll be president for four more years
yes
simple and yet deep
and insightful for sure um
[Music]
let's see bowser says the lincoln
project
leaked tiffany's speech and it was
identical they have also
leaked pompeos and they're going to leak
eric's i wonder how they're getting them
i don't fully understand that that's
interesting zachary says we desperately
need a steve bannon appearance oh he's
just like a coffee boy guys why would he
be here
chef's pawn says are you still in
amazement that they still try to draw
similarities from lincoln to trump
they do realize the party flipped
ideology after lincoln died
they don't realize anything they don't
realize anything
if you're if you're here's the way you
have to think about this
if they do something and then you say
do they realize that x the answer is no
they don't realize it that you can if
you bet that way
you will most likely be right most of
the time
um cooper asks i wonder why baron isn't
speaking
word is he doesn't agree with his
father's politics i've never heard that
i think it's just a kid and they're
keeping a kid out of it
um michael anton sue says love your show
zilloid the omni ziltoid the omniscient
says mother always did love weekends at
the cabin yes very very much so
uh oscar blakeberg or blackberg says if
bush showed up here
trump would grab it nicely done nicely
done
thank you to cat daddy eddie for
subscribing with
prime over on twitch as well as dad is
cranky
s cargo skill comrade shorty
cravens and a bunch of other folks
we are very slowly but surely building
up
our presence on twitch a lot of people
want to have uh
want to get a word in today a sweet baby
blade foot says they can't hold up teddy
roosevelt as a great
republican because he a trust buster and
conservationist
yeah they trump doesn't mention teddy
roosevelt too much but he has mentioned
him before
uh in certain situations not
super frequently uh let's listen in a
little bit to what's going on
when crystal said that she was looking
for a family to adopt her baby
god showed me exactly what i had to do
without hesitation
i told her that my family would welcome
her baby through adoption
today our beautiful daughter hope is a
thriving two-year-old
crystal is fast approaching three years
of recovery
she is a dear friend and a constant
inspiration
to me and others i hold a special place
in my heart for those facing opioid
addiction
and that's why i'm enormously grateful
to the president
for his leadership in fighting this
deadly enemy
through his efforts we're turning the
tide on the crisis of addiction
president trump declared the opioid
crisis to be a public health emergency
and then secured six billion dollars in
new federal funding to help americans
fight
opioid abuse he invested an additional
100 million dollars to stop the opioid
crisis
in rural america and in a move that
strikes at the root
of the problem he implemented a safer
prescribing plan
aimed at reducing opioid prescriptions
by over
a third within three years this is an
effort
that stops addiction before it ever
gains a hold in someone's life
and it's having an impact drug overdose
deaths
decreased in 2018 for the first time in
30 years many of the state's hardest hit
by the opioid crisis
are seeing the largest drop in deaths
we're seeing that doctors are writing
fewer prescriptions
for opioid pain drugs these are
significant
improvements that have a meaningful
impact
i think we are fortunate america to have
a president
who cares deeply for the downtrodden and
who works tirelessly
to find solutions a president who
doesn't just
talk about problems but stops and helps
not the trump i've seen president trump
is the leader we've needed the last four
years
and he is the leader we need for the
next four you see
donald trump is the right president at
the right time
let's make sure he's reelected on
november 3rd
i pray god's blessings on you and your
family and may god
bless america
okay here is
good evening my name is jeanette nunez
and i'm proud to serve
as lieutenant governor of the great
state of florida okay
tonight i'm honored to share my story of
faith
family i heard that she's really kooky
let's see
as the daughter of cuban immigrants my
story began
in 1959 before i was born
when my parents dreams of a prosperous
life
became a nightmare chaos spurred quickly
when fidel castro took control of cuba
the government confiscated private
property stealing people's homes
farms and businesses for my parents
the difficult decision to flee communist
cuba
came when the castro regime abolished
religious freedom
fellow americans the fabric of our
nation is in peril
so we're going to get back to this it's
it's this sort of anti-castro
cuban-american
propaganda she may start sort of
building up and crescendoing like
kimberly guilfoyle but i do want to get
to a very powerful super chat this is
the biggest super chat of the night
uh and it may not be exceeded william
downes
says thank you for helping those like
myself
that need deprogramming here we go now
from a lifetime of conservatism
get their minds straight you are an
inspiration keep it up william
thank you i'm glad uh i was able to help
and i really appreciate the uh
the generous super chat let's get back
to the wackiness happening at the rnc
and government control or we can choose
the path of freedom
and opportunity that was paved by those
who sacrificed everything to preserve
the american dream
for future generations i have faith
that americans will choose the right
path in 2016
our country yearned for a leader who
would work tirelessly
to jump start our economy and fight for
hard-working americans
remember job growth slowed when obama
left and trump came into office
erica first his pro-growth pro-jobs
agenda
has ushered in historically low
unemployment
record job creation higher wages
and rising home ownership the president
is fighting
to rescue american jobs and industries
for places like ohio
pennsylvania and puerto rico jobs that
were needlessly shipped overseas
he's defended our religious freedom
stood with democratic allies like
colombia
and shown unwavering resolve while
confronting tyrants
in countries like venezuela cuba
china and nicaragua let us join
our president what exactly has done
trump done to confront
cuba that's i mean it's like i know he
wants to and that's the rhetoric but
what has he actually done
president requires action join me
tonight
mandarin chief who has a bold agenda
that safeguards the rights
and freedoms protected under our
constitution
mother of three and the first latina
lieutenant governor it's interesting how
the closed captions are like a sentence
or two ahead of the speech
to share my story which is really your
story
and the story of a nation that has
opened its doors
lifted its people and yielded success
in a way only the united states of
america can
together let's ensure four more years
for president donald j trump so that he
can continue protecting our republic
and so one day our children can proudly
tell the story
of what our generation did to defend the
values
of faith family
and freedom thank you may god bless each
one of you
and may god bless the united states of
america
completely whacked out speech to get us
only 15 minutes from
melania trump who we are expecting very
soon uh
here's an interesting question from
prankish track who asks via youtube
super chat do you think the rnc will
cling to trump if he loses or give up
they'll just do nothing for the for the
lame duck period and then they'll be
gone
uh let's see what this is about
let me briefly just switch streams uh i
think that this
president for hosting this
naturalization ceremony here at the
white house
to our candidates it is my honor to
administer the oath of allegiance
and welcome you as our fellow citizens
candidates for naturalization please
raise your right hand
and repeat after me i hereby declare
an oath that i absolutely and entirely
renounce and observe
it's a naturalization ceremony but you
would think they're almost pledging
allegiance to trump
of the united states of america of the
united states of america
against all enemies against all enemies
foreign
[Music]
this is completely crazy i mean this is
like the
the worst combination
of unhinged nationalism
jingoism pandering
identity politics what am i missing
but i know that there's more here i just
don't know what i'm what i'm missing bae
photo says
is he going to do a deportation ceremony
next that that would be something
that would be something um unhinged
propaganda
tokenism it is certainly tokenism
fear-mongering garbage
yes fascism not so much
um okay jeez
[Applause]
on behalf of the department of homeland
security it is my honor to call
security it is my honor to call you my
fellow americans
mr president i want to again commend you
for your dedication to the rule of law
and for restoring integrity to our
immigration system thank you
the naturalization ceremony which
praises trump at the white house today
thank you very much congratulations
that's fantastic
it's really great thank you
and i want to thank acting secretary
wolf doing a
phenomenal job in so many ways today
america rejoices as we welcome
five absolutely incredible new members
into our great
american family you are now fellow
citizens of the greatest nation
on the face of god's earth
congratulations
all right people are angry that the sink
hasn't been fixed so we'll go back
on the face of god's earth
congratulations
great going you followed the rules you
obeyed the laws
you learned your history embraced our
values and proved yourselves to be
men and women of the highest integrity
it's not so easy you went through a lot
and we appreciate you being here with us
today yeah sort of a look at my
african-american moment except it's look
at my immigrants as
rising phoenix points out via super chat
useless possession
anywhere in the world it's called
american citizenship
there is no higher honor and no greater
privilege
not super useful now can't get into many
countries with that passport
thank you very much at this time i'd
like to recognize the five new citizens
who join us
today robert martin
ramirez alcazar is from bolivia
and has been a lawful permanent resident
of the united states since 2013.
robert hi robert
he and his wife are raising three
beautiful children
in 2017 robert achieved the dream of
starting his own business
a construction company that now employs
five workers
robert says i love this country i want
to respect the law
america has helped me so much in life
robert thank you very much for your
devotion thank you
for the pure trinities to the united
states well thank you
and good luck with that company soon
you'll have hundreds of employees i
think right
that could have could happen it will
rima gideon is from lebanon and is the
proud mother of three
children rima speaks english arabic and
french and earned a degree in
psychology in other words she can figure
me out
she now works as a daycare teacher in
virginia
riemer says i feel blessed to be a loyal
citizen of the greatest country in the
world
a country that has given me the
opportunity of a lifetime to realize my
potential and my dreams
rhema congratulations it's really great
thank you
so that's very good thank you very much
i think the ramirez guide just blinked
morse code for torture
murray narayan
is a phenomenal
success born in india came to the united
states
13 years ago suda is a talented software
developer and
she and her husband are raising two
beautiful
wonderful children the apples of your
life
right well thank you very much and
congratulations
fantastic job thank you name it
abdulzyme awolo side
whoa from sudan and that's a beautiful
name that's some risky reading there
senate residents since 2012 she is the
married mother of three beautiful
children earned a master's degree and
phd in
animal nutrition from the university of
wyoming great place
great state and she is a trained
veterinarian
she's also worked as a substitute
teacher
for the alexandria public schools since
2004. that's fantastic
well thai diabetes thank you very much
and congratulations
it's my honor to be with you thank you
thank you very much
salah abdul samad has been looking
forward to this day since he arrived in
the united states from ghana
in 2015 sally
speaks five languages and works the
medical field
sally says that the american citizenship
means
everything to me in my life it cannot be
measured or quantified
i have the chance to work hard and all
these five people are voting biden right
know that i am in the safe country like
america
that really is something because i know
they have my back
sally thank you very much
congratulations fantastic job
congratulations to everybody with the
rights and freedoms each of you now
enjoys the citizens there is no dream
beyond
your wildest reach because americans can
do
anything today you have also accepted
the profound
duties and responsibilities that come
with
american citizenship by swearing the
oath of allegiance
how has trump not gotten coronavirus yet
unbreakable covenant
with our nation you have pledged your
undying loyalty to the american people
the american constitution
and the american way of life the history
and heritage of the united states are
now yours to preserve and pass down
to the next generation our culture our
traditions and our values are now yours
to uphold and live by
the right so dear to every american
granted by
us and granted by god
and enshrined in our glorious bill of
rights
are now yours to support protect
yeah it's a good point in the chat this
this might almost turn off some of
trump's base
it's you know i guess the idea is could
it bring some centrists who are worried
trump's a xenophobic lunatic but does it
risk turning off some people in trump's
base a fair question
flag congratulations again to all of you
may god bless you and may god bless
our great country america
it's a good message breeze if if
democrats did this uh
it would be heads would fly would roll
it would be insane
okay eric trump uh not known as the
smart one remember
good evening america when i stood on
this convention stage four years ago
no one fully understood the historic
change that was about to take place
right we could all feel it something was
happening
yep a movement was forming just below
the surface
the forgotten man and woman voiceless in
washington dc
were preparing to rise up our movement
followed the pattern of so many that
came before us
first we were ignored then we were
laughed at
then they fought us and then together
we won what a disgusting from that
moment forward america came first
america started winning again america
became respected again
but with every movement there's a
counter movement yeah we're a little
laughing stock now that's america is the
source of the world's problems
as a result they believe the only path
forward is to raise history
and forget the past they want to destroy
the monuments of our forefathers
they want to disrespect our flag burn
the stars and stripes that represent
patriotism
and the american dream they want to
disrespect our national anthem by taking
a knee
while our armed forces lay down their
lives every day
to protect our freedom they do not want
the pledge of allegiance in our schools
many of them don't want one nation under
god
the democrats want to defund and
disrespect our law enforcement
the democrats want a miracle where your
thoughts and opinions are censored when
they do not align with their own
president reagan said freedom is never
more than one generation away from
extinction
it must be fought for and it must be
protected this
is the fight that we are in right now
and what's crazy is this
these would be reasonable things to say
to justify removing donald trump
not re-electing him well because he knew
hard-working people across this great
country were being left behind
the media mocked these patriots in the
flyover states in which they lived
they ignored the trump flags they
ignored the millions of mega banners and
barns painted in red
white and blue the silent majority had
no one fighting for them in either party
their so-called leaders were bowing to
china bribing iran
and spending more time worrying about
how they'd be received by the elites in
paris
than how americans would provide for
their families in pittsburgh
our family lost friends but it only
pushed us to fight harder
my father pledged to every american in
every city
state and town that he was going to make
america great again
and so began the great american comeback
almost immediately taxes were slashed
regulations were cut
and the economy soared to new heights
heights never seen before
wages went through the roof unemployment
reached the historic lows especially for
black americans
hispanic americans and women trade deals
were ripped up and renegotiated
lights were turned back on in abandoned
factories across our country
trillions of dollars were repatriated
back to the united states
which had been sitting in foreign lands
for far too long
once again america became the envy of
the world
and with that renewed strength came
leverage the president demanded that our
allies pay their fair share for the
defense of the western world
my father rebuilt the mighty american
military adding new jets
aircraft carriers he increased wages for
incredible men and women in uniform
this guy is so lame like even it's just
everything about this delivery is lame
the content obviously is lame but it's
like who
what your people are glazing over
the moment president trump ordered
special forces kill some of the
deadliest terrorists on the planet
the day the mighty moab was dropped on
the surging camps
is the day america took a stance and
never be defeated
by the enemy al-baghdadi soleimani
dead over and over issue after issue
the economy the wall the military trade
deals tax cuts
supreme court justices va hospitals
prescription drugs school choice
right to try moving the embassy to
jerusalem
peace in the middle east never ending
wars were finally ended
promises made and promises for the first
time were kept
most politicians spend their entire
careers in washington dc and get
absolutely nothing accomplished
for example joe biden joe biden is a
politician who has been in government
for 47
years he's a career politician who's
never signed the front of a check
and does not know the slightest thing
about the american worker
or the american business the engine
which fuels the greatest economy the
world has ever known
the same politician who has been a total
pushover for communist china
and someone who would be a giant relief
for terrorists who now spend years
running hiding and being taken out by
the most talented
military known to man
joe biden has pledged to raise your
taxes by 4 trillion
82 percent of americans will see their
taxes go up significantly
live biden has pledged to stop border
wall construction
and give amnesty and health care
to all illegal immigrants fighting his
pledge to defund the police
and take away your cherished second
amendment lie
my father on the other hand delivered
the largest tax cuts in american history
knows if you do not have a border you do
not have a country
and will always support law enforcement
and your right to keep
and bear arms
every day my father fights for the
american people the forgotten man
and woman of this country the ones who
embody the american spirit
which is unlike anything else in the
world
it built the new york city skyline it
built the hoover dam
and soon under my father's leadership it
will send
americans to mars what
the shadows of mount rushmore and the
stillness
of the era gettysburg it can be seen in
the wide-eyed wonder of
every american child as they take their
first breath
in the greatest country the world has
ever known
it defeated fascism it defeated
communism
and in 68 days it will defeat the empty
oppressive and radical views of the
extreme left
oh my god ronald reagan's quote ends
with this
simple warning one day we could spend
our sunset years telling our children
what it was once like in the united
states where men
and women were free under president
trump freedom will never be a thing of
the past
that's what a vote for donald trump
represents it's a vote for the american
spirit
the american dream and for the american
flag
to the law enforcement officer who's
being attacked
betrayed and whose job they are trying
to make extinct
my father will fight for you
to all houses of worship and to all
people of faith stripped of our
religious freedoms
like an aircraft carrier please my
father
will fight for you to the voiceless
shamed censored and cancelled my father
will fight for you
to our farmers who work dawn to dust to
keep our plates full
my father will fight for you to every
single mother and father to our veterans
our coal miners and to the american
worker
my father will fight for you and to
every proud american who bleeds
red white and blue my father will
continue
to fight for you
in closing i'd like to speak directly to
my father in conclusion i miss working
alongside you every single day
but i'm damn proud to be on the front
lines of this fight
i'm proud of what you're doing for this
country i'm proud to show my children
what their grandfather is fighting for
i'm proud to watch you give them hell
never stop continue to be unapologetic
keep fighting for what is right you are
making america strong again
you are making america safe again here
we go you are making america proud again
and yes together with a forgotten man
and woman who are finally forgotten no
more
you are making america great again
taking a while
dad let's make uncle robert very proud
this week
let's go get another four years i love
you
very much god bless you and god bless
the united states of america
so now getting down to i think just
melania trump is the only major speech
that is left donald trump wildly there
claiming that he is going to get us to
mars something that
actual scientists have been working on
for a very long time
trump i guess going to get us to mars in
the next four years
um and of course if that happens there
will be plans that date back to before
trump was president so it's all just a
little bit weird this is a great
opportunity to get your super chats in
um jake says see you later liberals
you're yolo on my big beautiful shiny
ship to mars where the big
brains live yes jim wagstaff says i'm
taking crazy pills yeah we all feel like
we are
kevin wilkie says david thank you to you
and your team for your tireless work
raising the value proposition and
industry standard of independent media
thank you for feeding our intellectual
curiosities with integrity
and class novemos thanks kevin and
like i promised i'll return that 25
bucks to you via venmo later i
appreciate you uh
doing me the favor of sending that super
chat a few other
people to thank cody mullins
is new member number 26 today
michael jarrod is number 27.
concave juju is number 28.
patricia tongate is number 29. brian
maddox is number 30. christian lee is
number 31 wow things are happening
nico pulos is number 32
and david beraki is number 33
very much appreciate that support uh
indeed we are now standing by for
melania trump it looks like this is some
kind of maybe
pseudo introduction to her i think her
speech will be interesting nonetheless
um super guy asks a brilliant question
which is can someone please explain
why the hell are they're still undecided
voters
that do people need what do people need
at this point i think is the question
beautiful question beautiful question
kilgore says
only time eric can tell dad he loves him
is on tv
well said oscar blackberg says you have
to tell me what trump has to do with
going to mars
i'm going there to get away from all of
this yeah trump has nothing to do with
it it's
uh it's anything he can try to take
credit for he's going to try to
convalescent plasma plasma going to mars
a vaccine developed in the uk i mean
anything he can take credit for he's
going to try to
um and i think it's important that we
all remember that so we don't fall for
it i i don't think i'm going to fall for
it but
it's certainly conceivable that somebody
might
oh i do apologize i missed two people
before
megan whitfield is new member number 33.
uh let's go to this speech my name is
daniel cameron
i'm 34 years old and the first
african-american attorney general in
kentucky history
it is an honor to be with you as a proud
republican
and supporter of donald j trump i was
raised in kentucky
just a few miles from abraham lincoln's
birthplace
our first republican president believed
in compassion
self-reliance freedom equality
and justice sadly
there are some who don't believe in this
wisdom or in the better angels
of our shared american history as they
tear down the statues of people like
ulysses s
grant frederick douglass and even mr
lincoln himself
lincoln said in which lincoln statues
have been torn down is that true
will not long endure and for republicans
our heroes are those who propelled an
imperfect nation
ever forward always striving to make
life better
for everyone even as anarchists
mindlessly tear up american cities while
attacking police
and innocent bystanders we republicans
do recognize those who work in good
faith
towards peace justice and equality
in fact it was general dwight eisenhower
a future republican president
who said democracy is a system that
recognizes
the equality of humans before the law
whether you are the family of brianna
taylor or david dorn
these are the ideals that will heal our
nation's wounds
republicans will never turn a blind eye
to unjust acts
but neither will we accept an all-out
assault
on western civilization
my values were shaped by my faith and by
my parents
i worked at their small coffee shop
meeting people from all walks of life
and i realized something no matter who
we are
everyone needs a cup of coffee that
lesson stuck with me because despite
our differences we all want the same
things
for our children to have more
opportunities than we did
to feel the dignity of work and to
believe that if you play by the rules
you can make a good life for yourself
and your family
so the question is will we choose the
path that gives us the best chance
to meet those universal desires or will
we go back
to a time when people were treated like
political commodities
who can't be trusted to think for
themselves
i think often about my ancestors who
struggled for freedom
and as i think of those giants and their
broad shoulders
i also think about joe biden who says if
you aren't voting for me
you ain't black who argued that
republicans
would put us back in chains oh boy who
says there is no diversity of thought
in the black community there's no like
arc to this speech
look at me i am black we are not all the
same sir
i am not in chains my mind is my own
and you can't tell me how to vote
because of the color of my skin
joe biden is a backwards thinker in a
world that is
craving forward-looking leadership
there's no wisdom in his record or plan
just a trail of discredited ideas and
offensive statements
joe biden would destroy jobs raise our
taxes
and throw away the lives of countless
unborn children
just a reminder job growth is higher and
unemployment tends to be lower during
democratic administrations you can talk
about correlation versus causation but
that's the facts
must dictate your politics and if you
fail to conform while exercising your
god-given right to speak and think
freely
they will cut you down
the politics of identity cancellation
and mob rule
are not acceptable to me he's
criticizing identity politics but has
mentioned his race multiple times during
this speech
your american dream however you see fit
mr lincoln said the dogmas of the quiet
past are inadequate to the stormy
present
the occasion is piled high with
difficulty and we
must rise to the occasion i believe
donald trump can meet lincoln's mandate
even as joe biden remains trapped by his
own failed record
and by the radicals who dominate his
party
let's be honest no one is excited about
joe biden
and so i asked you to judge the record
on criminal justice reform
joe biden couldn't do it but president
trump
did on the economy joe biden
couldn't do it but president trump did
build an economy
that worked for everyone especially
minorities
and he will do it again and on
immigration
joe biden promises more to illegal
immigrants
than he does to you but president trump
believes
his highest duty is to the american
worker
the choice is clear let me close with
something my mom told me
this country's many faces comprise a
family
not separate parts to be divided against
each other
and like any family we care for one
another we grieve together
we share our burdens and our struggles
and we celebrate
our successes and though we fuss and
fight
we are not enemies we are americans
united by a collective faith in our
constitution
and laws and the fundamental fairness
they represent
we are defenders of life and of
individual liberty
and we carry the mantle of eisenhower
and of reagan
to be a force for good in this world and
one that must
always be reckoned with that's my
republican party
the party of lincoln that believes
america is an
indispensable nation an evergreen tree
standing tall in a turbulent world
and that's why i am voting for donald
trump
for president thank you and god bless
so another speech riddled with identity
politics
crowbaring it in uh now it's pompeo and
then melania presumably
looking out over the old city i have a
big job
as susan's husband and nick's dad
susan and nick are more safe and their
freedom's more secure
because president trump has put his
america first vision into action
it may not have made him popular in
every foreign capital but it's worked
president trump understands what my
great fellow kansan president eisenhower
said
for all that we cherish and justly
desire for ourselves
or for our children the securing of
peace is the first requisite
indeed the primary constitutional
function of the national government is
ensuring that your family
and mine are safe and enjoy the freedom
to live
to work to learn and to worship as they
choose
delivering on this duty to keep us safe
and our freedoms intact
this president has led bold initiatives
in nearly every corner of the world
in china he's pulled back the curtain on
the predatory aggression
of the chinese communist party the
president has held china accountable for
covering up the china virus
and allowing it to spread death and
economic destruction in america
and around the world and he will not
rest until justice is done
he has ensured that the chinese
communist party spies posing as
diplomats in america
or jailed or sent back to china and he
has ended the ridiculously unfair trade
arrangement
with china that punched a hole in our
economy
those jobs those jobs are coming back
home
in north korea the president lowered the
temperature
and against all odds got the north
korean leadership to the table
no nuclear tests no long-range missile
tests yet there is an alex jones vibe to
mike pompeo that's a good point denver
is that the precious remains of scores
of heroes who fought
in korea today today because of
president trump nato is stronger
ukraine has defensive weapon systems and
america left a harmful treaty so our
nation can now build missiles
to deter russian aggression and in the
middle east
when iran threatened the president
approved a strike that killed the
iranian terrorist
qasim suleimani this is the man most
responsible for the murder and maiming
of hundreds of american soldiers
and thousands of christians across the
middle east
and you'll recall too that when the
president took office
radical islamic terrorists had beheaded
americans and isis controlled a
territory in the size of the size of
great britain
today today because of the president's
determination and leadership
the isis caliphate is wiped out it's
gone it's evil leader
abu bakr al-baghdadi is dead and our
brave soldiers
they're on their way home the president
exited
the u.s from the disastrous nuclear deal
with iran and squeezed the ayatollah
hezbollah
and hamas the president too
moved the u.s embassy to this very city
of god jerusalem
the rightful capital of the jewish
homeland
and just two weeks ago the president
brokered a historic
peace deal between israel and the united
arab emirates
this is the deal that our grandchildren
will read about in their history books
i doubt that you know as a soldier i saw
firsthand
people desperate to flee to freedom the
way each of us
can best ensure our freedoms is by
electing leaders who don't just talk
but who deliver an american hostage
imprisoned in turkey for two years
pastor andrew brunson
said upon his release that he survived
his ordeal with these words of scripture
be faithful endure and finish well
if we stay the course we will
may god richly bless you and may god
bless our great nation the united states
of america
all right so short remarks from mike
pompeo and then hear the much
anticipated with a crowd
in fact rose garden speech
from melania trump upcoming
although this seems to be mike and karen
pence
um it i believe this is the lead up
to the melania speech and this could get
pretty ugly this could get really bad so
we're going to see momentarily here
um wow
wow this i had no idea that they were
going to have a crowd but it's
all extremely propagandistic
and of course not socially distant
either as you can probably tell
here's trump coming out to the requisite
applause clapping for himself as well
man this has got to be weird sitting
there
having trump sit there while melania
speaks
and why isn't he with melania by the way
it's very strange
everything about this is weird oh and
extra orange today as well
oh my god it is my great honor to
present
the first lady melania trump first lady
melania trump
first lady melania trump officially
kicking off her best friend
she is courageous she's taking we just
learned from one of her former advisors
stephanie winston or something like that
that uh when melania proposed be best
her advisor said
that sounds like illiteracy and yet they
pushed forward with it just
wacky wacky stuff it brings to the
position of first lady
she is smart independent and i think
people have underestimated her big time
the first lady was amazing she was
gracious
empathetic and showed true compassion
first lady melania trump stepping out
onto the world stage
the b based campaign is now going
international
she has the advantage of speaking
several languages
she can be a diplomat for it's not clear
that's been an advantage for her as
first lady but
her continuing to work on her best
campaign by shining a spotlight on
successful programs
that teach children tools and skills he
represents our country
enormous warmth and elegance and grace
throughout history women have made
lasting
impacts on society and these women
represent the strength
of the female spirit as first lady of
the united states
i'm proud of what this country continues
to do for women
we as women must continue this is going
to be a great speech guys
empowerment our voices it was a very
important moment for milani trump this
was a really prominent week for her the
iconic
white house rose garden has been
renovated for the first
time in 60 years when the history books
are written
and it looks like they removed the roses
which is not the way i would go in the
rose garden but what i'm not a
horticulturist
an incredible woman lady
melania trump
all right the keynote for day two
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
first lady of the united states
mrs melania trump
i'm cringing already
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
very long
[Music]
it's like a package
good evening it seems
like just yesterday that we were at our
first convention
where my husband accepted the republican
nomination
and then became our 45th president
of the united states yet the energy
and enthusiasm for who should lead this
nation
it is real today as it was four years
ago
i know i speak for my husband and the
entire family
when i say we have not forgotten the
incredible people
who were willing to take a chance on the
businessmen
who had never worked in politics it was
a bad chance we know it was you
who elected him to be commander in chief
and we know it is you who will carry us
through again we were humbled by the
incredible support
then and we are still grateful today
i want to acknowledge the fact that
since march
our lives have changed drastically
the invisible enemy coveted 19
swept across our beautiful country and
impacted
all of us my deepest sympathy
goes out to everyone who has lost
a loved one and my prayers are with
those
who are ill or suffering
i know many people are anxious
and some feel helpless i want you to
know
you're not alone my husband's
administration
will not stop fighting until there is an
effective treatment
or vaccine i didn't know they started
fighting everyone
donald will not rest until he has done
all he can to take care of everyone
impacted by this terrible pandemic
i want to extend my gratitude to all of
the health care professionals
frontline workers and teachers who
stepped up
in these difficult times despite the
risk to yourselves
and your own families you put our
country first and my husband
and i are grateful
i have been moved by the way americans
have come together in such an
unfamiliar and often frightening
situation
it is in times like this that we will
look back
and tell our grandchildren that through
kindness
and compassion strength and
determination
we were able to restore the promise of
our future
businesses stepped up and volunteers
stepped in
people were eager to share ideas
resources
and support of all kinds with neighbors
and strangers alike
it has been inspiring to see what the
people of our great nation will do for
one another
especially when we are at our most
fragile
of strength and determination we
recently celebrated
the 100 year anniversary of the passage
of the 19th amendment yeah trump
pardoned susan b anthony and the people
in the room thought it was a joke
of the white house we unveiled an
exhibit
dedicated to women's suffrage
the exhibit called on children from
across the country
to send art honoring the meaning of this
important time
in women's history when i was judging
the entries
i reflected on the impact of women's
voices
in our nation's story and how proud i
will be to cast my vote
again for donald this november
we must make sure that women are heard
and that american dream continues to
thrive
growing up as a young child in slovenia
which was unbelievable criticizing the
fact that she's in english as a second
language speaker or eighth language or
i i think that's sort of you know what
she's saying is ridiculous but
you know people have accents when they
learn languages after
age 12 typically i don't know that
that's much of anything i mean i think
the reality is she didn't want any of
this she just wanted to you know
be some rich dude's wife and have a kid
and fly around on a private jet and
okay it didn't work out but her accent
come on prosper in america
but also contribute to a nation that
allows for people
to arrive with a dream and make it
reality
i want to take the moment to thank my
mother
and father for all they have done for
our family
it is because of you that i'm standing
here today
[Applause]
i arrived in united states when i was 26
years old
living and working in the land of
opportunity
was a dream come true but i wanted more
i wanted to be a citizen after 10 years
of paperwork and patience i studied for
the test
in 2006 and became an american citizen
the delay on the applause makes it
cringe now
it is still one of the proudest moments
in my life because
with hard work and determination i was
able to achieve my own american dream
as an immigrant and a very independent
woman
i understand what a privilege it is to
live here
and to enjoy the freedoms and
opportunities
that we have as first lady
i have been fortunate to see the
american dream
come true over and over again
i have met many inspiring women
children parents and families
who have overcome life-changing issues
that include addiction homelessness
family members who are ill or have
passed away
abuse of all kinds and many other
challenges
that would make most people give up the
past
three and a half years have been
unforgettable
there are no words to describe how
honored
humbled and fortunate i am to serve
our nation as your first lady
after many of the experiences i've had
i don't know if i can fully explain how
many people
i take home with me in my heart each day
from brave soldiers who give up so much
so that we can be free to children of
all circumstances this seems so
disingenuous to me i don't know what you
guys think
for inspiring me it is my greatest honor
to serve you when i speak to members of
the military
despite sacrificing time with their
families
experience the fear of war or suffering
loss
they have no regrets about serving our
country
the same goes for their families and the
families of first responders
who often watch their loved ones walk
out the door
not sure if or when they will come home
when i speak to families who have lost
someone
the pain mixed with pride i hear in
their voices
is something i think about often
so thank you to all who serve our
country in the military
sky in the left's on his phone as you
can see there are a couple masks in the
crowd to the families
who wait for them you are heroes
in your own right i think kim jong-un
wore this outfit better guys i don't
know about you hopefully we'll see some
kind of fashion review tomorrow
hospitals
schools and other locations around the
world
children who are dealing with pain or
illness that would break even the
strongest adult
parents who are grateful to wake up
every day and see that their child is
still alive
these families are a testament to what
faith and medicine strength and
science can do
on my first international trip as first
lady
my husband and i visited places of great
significance
to the three major religions okay
significance is interesting
what do you guys think trump's thinking
about right now one special memory from
that trip
is of a young boy i had privilege of
visiting
while at bambino jizu hospital in rome
italy
while there i read a little boy a story
and learned that he and his family had
been waiting for a heart
for a very long time and he had a green
prognosis
his situation brought my staff and me to
tears
and we spoke of a little else as we flew
to belgium
for the next part of our trip
upon landing just a few hours later we
learned
that a heart had been donated and would
be going
to the little one i think about him
often
along with so many amazing and strong
young patients
across our own country
more profound and sadly unavoidable
examples
of our country's strength and character
have occurred in the communities that
have been impacted by natural disasters
hurricanes tornadoes and flooding may
show the ugly side of mother nature
it does seem like you guys are
recognizing what i'm recognizing which
is that there's absolutely no
there's number one there's no coherent
message here and number two
there's nothing here that justifies
reelecting donald trump those are my two
takeaways
and we are deeply moved by the strength
of the people
who have lost everything and the
kindness
of neighbors and communities
the common thread in all of these
challenging situations
is the unwavering resolve to help one
another
i recognize the stories i just told
about people who survive
extraordinary circumstances but donald
and i
are also inspired by the millions of
americans
who wake up each day with a simple yet
courageous goal
of providing for their families and
keeping them safe
you are the backbone of this country
you are the people who continue to make
the united states of america what it is
and who have the incredible
responsibility
of preparing our future generations to
leave
everything even better than they found
it
just as you are fighting for your
families
my husband our family and the people
in this administration are here fighting
for you
no matter the amount of negative or
false media headlines
or attacks from the other side donald
trump
has not and will not lose focus on you
he loves this country and he knows how
to get things done
as you have learned over the past five
years he's not a traditional politician
he doesn't just speak words he demands
action
and he gets results the future of our
country
has always been very important to him
and it is something
that i have always admired
in fact it is to help ensure a better
future
for our next generation that i launched
be best
my initiative to help children achieve
their fullest potential
be bast has one simple goal teaching
youth
about the importance of their well-being
both mentally and physically
this also includes understanding online
safety
and the dangers of opioid and drug abuse
to be best my office and i have been
able to highlight people
programs and organizations that are
doing
extraordinary things in our country and
around the world
i continue i continue to believe that by
shining a lie
it's mostly an inoffensive speech i mean
it's completely devoid of any meaning
and content but it's
relatively inoffensive other than the
parts where she praises trump
our next generation helping children
is not a political goal it is our
moral imperative when i think back
to a defining moment of be best my mind
goes to a trip i took to africa during
which she came up with the name on that
vast and beautiful continent
i was able to visit the countries of
ghana
malawi kenya and egypt
one of those visits in particular had a
profound
impact on me ghana
on the coast of west africa was the
first stop on my trip
and i experienced firsthand its warm
people
and their traditions while there
i visited the cape coast castle and
learned more about the beginning
of a cruel and often deadly journey in
the era
of the slave trade i was horrified
when i listened to the guide tell me so
many inhumane stories
and i gained new perspectives
it is time in our history
we must never forget so that we can
ensure
that it never happens again
like all of you i have reflected on the
racial unrest
in our country it is a harsh reality
that we are not proud of parts of our
history
i encourage people to focus on our
future
while still learning from our past
slavery was bad but let's focus on the
future we are all
one community comprised of many races
religions and ethnicities our diverse
and storied history is what makes our
country strong
and yet we still have so much to learn
from one another with that in mind
i like to call on the citizens of this
country
to take a moment pause and look at
things from all perspectives
i urge people to come together in a
civil manner
so we can work and live up to our
standard
american ideals i also the super chats
are not particularly pleased with this
speech
being done in the name of justice and
never make assumptions
based on the color of a person's skin
instead of tearing things down tearing
things down
let's reflect on our mistakes
be proud of our evolution and look
to our way forward
every day let us remember that we are
one nation
under god and we need to cherish one
another
my husband's administration has worked
to try and affect change when it comes
to issues around
race and religion in this country
he is the first president to address a
special
sensation of the united nations general
assembly
to call upon countries across the world
to end religious prosecution
and honor the right of every person
to worship as they choose
he has made substantial investments in
our historically black colleges
and universities this president
also continues to fight for school
choice
giving parents more options to help
their children
flourish my husband knows
how to make a real change from the day
that i met him he has only wanted to
make this country the best
it can be for many years i watched him
grow concerned and frustrated
and i'm so proud to see the many things
he has done
i think it is too long and unfocused
yeah it should have been significantly
shorter
hard so while at times we only see the
worst
of people and politics on the evening
news
let's remember how we come together
in the most difficult times
and while the bait rage on about issues
of race
let's focus on the strides we have made
and work together
for a better tomorrow for everyone
trump's going to ream her out for this
speech right historic resources
and produced life-saving results by
raising awareness
around opioid addiction and drug abuse
especially for children when so often
the headlines
are filled with gossip i want to take
this moment to encourage the media
to focus even more on the nation's drug
crisis
this disease is one that affects
everybody
it pays no attention to race age
or see socioeconomic status
addiction has touched every part of oh i
thought she was actually going to talk
about coronavirus
and now more than ever we have programs
in medicine
to combat it we just need to talk about
it openly
and you the media have the platforms
to make that happen
to the media industry and as a country
i ask that we all commit to helping in
our fights against drug addiction
by talking about it even more
especially as we battle the covet
pandemic
we need to remember that suicides
are on the rise as people who are
struggling with
loneliness and addiction feel they have
nowhere to turn
who wrote this this is not good children
teachers and caregivers pay attention to
signs of addiction
lawmakers pass legislation that allows
those who ask for help
to do so safely and without fear
and to provide resources for
organizations
that help people impacted by addiction
i'm pretty sure melania just blinked
prenup in morse code no longer be
ashamed
to ask for help and lives will be saved
and if
if you're struggling with addiction
there is no shame
in your illness please seek help you are
worth it
in my next four years as first lady i
will continue to build upon the best and
work with individual state
to pass legislation to take care of our
most vulnerable
i plan to continue the work i have
started with children
in foster care as well as a minority
communities
and tribal nations i want to ensure
children
are being protected and communities have
the resources needed
to combat drug addiction and child
neglect or abuse
like my husband and the administration i
will continue to encourage
education that supports a child's
individual needs
it is vital that children are given the
building blocks
to succeed i wish she would comment on
whether she thinks stormy daniels got
too much money in the payoff
i'm curious what she thinks about that
quite frankly pride for our nation
i believe this iconic home needs to be
cared for
and preserved so it can be enjoyed by
the people
of this country and visitors from around
the world
for years to come i'm passionate about
this beautiful house
the grounds and all they represent
and now i have a special message for the
mothers of this country
this modern world is moving so fast
and our children face challenges that
seem
to change every few months just like me
i know many of you watch how me and
manipulative
social media can be and just like me
i'm sure many of you are looking for
answers
how to talk to your children about the
downside of technology
and their relationships with their peers
like every parent in this country i feel
there are so many left trump clearly
regretting this this
realizing this was a disastrous idea but
there are
just not enough hours in the day to do
it all
i remind myself that i'm more fortunate
than most
and still have days that i look for
wisdom and strength
to do the very best i can for him
to mothers and parents everywhere you
are warriors
in my husband you have a president who
will not stop
fighting for you and your families i see
how hard he works each day and night
and despite the unprecedented attacks
from the media and opposition
he will not give up in fact if you tell
him he cannot be done
he just works harder
donna bring the pros applause line wow
donald is a husband who supports me in
all that i do
he has built an administration with an
unprecedented number of women
in leadership roles and has fostered an
environment
where the american people are always the
priority
is it that bright there like why is
trump squinting so view
and encourage thinking outside of the
box
i know i speak for my husband and the
family when i say we are so grateful
that you have trusted him to be your
president
and we will be honored to serve this
incredible country
for four more years
as you have heard this evening i don't
want to use this precious time
attacking the other side because as we
saw last week
that kind of talk only serves to divide
the country further i'm here because we
need my husband to be our president
and commander-in-chief for four more
years
he is what is best for our country
we all know donald trump makes no
secrets
about how he feels about things
total honesty is what we as citizens
deserve from our
president whether you like it or not
you always know what he's thinking
and that is because he's an authentic
person
who loves this country and you guys
think they got enough pictures
continue to make it better
donald wants to keep your family safe he
wants to
help your family succeed he wants
nothing more
than for this country to prosper and he
doesn't waste time
playing politics that shutter has to be
broken right
went into election day completely
underestimated
despite what is being said again this
year i know just as you do
that americans will go to the polls and
roll
on the behalf of their families our
economy
our national security and our children's
future
to vote for those ideals is not a
partisan vote
it is a common sense vote because
those are goals and hopes that we all
believe in
i believe that we need my husband's
leadership now more than ever
in order to bring us back once again to
the greatest economy
and the strongest country ever known
god bless you all your families and god
bless the united states of america
wow
i guess she's saying we should vote for
trump right did she say we should vote
for trump it's not even really clear
or certainly she didn't say why i'm
confused as ever
[Applause]
oh boy
[Applause]
wow this is awkward guys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and off they go after an historic and
inspirational night defiant against all
of their
what the hell am i talking about no it
was idiotic
[Applause]
[Music]
i i really don't know what to make of it
just bizarre
it's like what stands out like remember
when she mentioned
bullying is bad like i remember her
saying that but then thinking how trump
bullies people all the time
yeah very not memorable in any way lady
melania and trump
okay guys i'm in a wrap it's uh that's
just it
i'm glad everybody was with me please
remember we are trying to get to a
million subscribers on youtube
and 50 000 followers on twitch so if
you're heading out
smash that subscribe button punch the
follow button
on twitch and i'll see everybody back
here
tomorrow
you